My name is Jan, I'm from Spain.
我叫简，来自西班牙。
I'm 22 right now.
我现在22岁了。
I started having my mother more or less when I was like 14 or 15.
我大约在 14 或 15 岁的时候就开始有妈妈了。
You know, when you're 14 or 15, you don't really get taught things about your feelings, how to manage them, how to deal with them, how to love.
你知道，当你14岁或15岁的时候，你并没有真正被教导关于你的感受、如何管理它们、如何处理它们、如何去爱。
And these characters from having your mother really taught me a lot about emotional intelligence, how to deal with my feelings, how to deal with people, how people feel about themselves as well.
这些来自你母亲的角色确实教会了我很多关于情商的知识，如何处理自己的感受，如何与人打交道，以及人们如何看待自己。
I think it truly made me a better person, and it had a big impact in how I grew up, especially emotionally.
我认为这确实让我成为了一个更好的人，并且对我的成长产生了很大的影响，尤其是在情感上。
And actually, I think when I was with my first girlfriend, the first time I told her I love you, I said, falafel instead, and she watched the show, also, so that was funny.
事实上，我想当我和我的第一个女朋友在一起时，我第一次告诉她我爱你，我说的是沙拉三明治，她也看了这个节目，所以这很有趣。
But yeah, thank you.
但是，是的，谢谢你。
Hello, I'm Josh Radner.
你好，我是乔什·拉德纳。
Welcome to another episode of how we made your mother.
欢迎收看我们如何塑造你母亲的另一集。
I'm joined as always by my friend, Craig Thomas.
我的朋友克雷格·托马斯一如既往地加入了我的行列。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
We also have our beloved producer and sometimes friend, Alec Lev here.
我们还有我们敬爱的制作人，有时也是朋友，亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev）也在这里。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
We're very excited.
我们非常兴奋。
We're talking about.
我们正在谈论。
He's always our friend.
他永远是我们的朋友。
What's your friend?
你的朋友是什么？
That's nice of you to say.
你说得真好。
We are talking about the sweet taste of liberty today, which first aired on television on October 3rd, 2005.
我们今天谈论的是自由的甜蜜滋味，该节目于 2005 年 10 月 3 日在电视上首次播出。
So on October 3rd, that'll be 20 years since this episode aired.
到 10 月 3 日，这一集播出已经过去 20 年了。
Oh my god.
我的天啊。
We just don't understand this math.
我们只是不明白这个数学。
I don't I think it's wrong.
我不认为这是错误的。
I think it's wrong.
我认为这是错误的。
We just agreed we would say the dates two seconds ago to contextualize it.
我们刚刚同意我们会说两秒前的日期以将其结合起来。
And as soon as you said it, I felt sad and old.
而你一说出这句话，我就感到悲伤和苍老。
I felt it.
我感觉到了。
But here we go.
但我们开始了。
Let's come through the room.
我们来穿过房间吧。
Yeah, the grim reaper.
是的，死神。
So okay.
那么好吧。
So sweet taste of liberty.
如此甜蜜的自由滋味。
This is episode three of 208, right?
这是208的第三集吧？
Episode three of two hundred a we're getting there.
第三集，共两百集，我们即将到达。
We're talking about.
我们正在谈论。
We've got a nice.
我们有一个很好的。
I mean last week was two.
我的意思是上周是两周。
This is this is we're really making progress.
这就是我们真正取得的进步。
We really are we're almost at the finish line.
我们真的快到终点线了。
Okay.
好的。
This is a fun one.
这是一件有趣的事。
I feel like parts one and two parts one and two episodes one and two felt like a two part.
我觉得第一部分和第二部分第一部分和第二部分第一集和第二集感觉像是两部分。
It felt like an hour show rewatching it really felt that way and this feels like it's own show in a way.
感觉就像重看一个小时的节目，真的有这种感觉，在某种程度上感觉就像是它自己的节目。
This is like also the show is this other thing that's a party cartoon.
这就像该节目是另一部派对卡通片。
That is exactly how the writers of this episode, the wonderful Chris Miller and Phil Lorde Miller, you might know them from the LEGO movies.
这正是本集的编剧，出色的克里斯·米勒和菲尔·洛德·米勒，你可能会从乐高电影中认识他们。
You might know them from 21 Jump Street, 22 Jump Street.
您可能在 21 Jump Street 和 22 Jump Street 认识他们。
You might know them from winning Oscars for the Spider-Verse movies, or at least Anne Oscar, for the first one they got robbed on that second one.
你可能通过《蜘蛛侠：宇宙》电影赢得奥斯卡奖而认识他们，或者至少是安妮·奥斯卡，因为他们在第一部影片中被抢了，但在第二部影片中却被抢劫了。
And they're amazing.
他们太棒了。
And they were writers in season one of how I met your mother and they wrote this episode.
他们是《我如何遇见你母亲》第一季的编剧，他们写了这一集。
Remind me, how did you, Did you guys work on Letterman Together?
提醒我，你们怎么样，你们一起参与《莱特曼》吗？
How did you know them?
你是怎么认识他们的？
We had the same agent.
我们有同一个经纪人。
Our agent Matt Rice, who I'll give a nice complement to here is, he was very young, he was only a couple of years older than all of us, and he had his initial client roster when he was a junior agent, it was like me and Carter, Will Forte and Chris and Phil, and a few other really, really cool people.
我们的经纪人马特·赖斯（Matt Rice），我要在这里给他一个很好的补充，他很年轻，只比我们所有人大几岁，当他还是初级经纪人时，他就有了最初的客户名单，就像我和卡特、威尔·福特、克里斯和菲尔，以及其他一些非常非常酷的人。
And it was just like, God the sky.
就像天空之神一样。
There is something to a good agent.
一个好的经纪人是有一些东西的。
I remember you telling me or maybe Chris and Phil told me that Chris was long time married and Phil was single mirroring you in Carter, right?
我记得你告诉过我，或者克里斯和菲尔告诉我，克里斯已经结婚很久了，菲尔单身，这与卡特的情况如出一辙，对吧？
Insanely mirroring me in Carter.
疯狂地模仿我的卡特。
Yeah.
是的。
Chris and Robin went to Dartmouth and fell in love and were together the entire time in Dartmouth.
克里斯和罗宾去了达特茅斯并坠入爱河，并在达特茅斯一直在一起。
I'm Craig.
我是克雷格。
My wife is Rebecca.
我的妻子是丽贝卡。
C and R.
C和R。
Chris and Robin, Craig and Rebecca.
克里斯和罗宾，克雷格和丽贝卡。
Craig and Rebecca, I'm going to talk about myself as the third person for the rest of the episode.
克雷格和丽贝卡，我将在这一集的其余部分中以第三人称的身份谈论我自己。
It's not going to be weird at all.
这一点也不奇怪。
do next.
接下来做。
Craig Craig and Rebecca they met those two met in college too and we're together all the way through college so it was like this writing team of a guy Chris who had a CNR college relationship and then his writing partner Phil was like a single guy like Carter was a single guy and we were just like writing.
克雷格·克雷格和丽贝卡他们两个也是在大学里认识的，我们在大学期间一直在一起，所以这就像是一个由克里斯组成的写作团队，他与 CNR 大学有关系，然后他的写作搭档菲尔就像一个单身的人，就像卡特一样，我们就像写作一样。
We were doppelgangers.
我们是分身。
I mean to you to use him you speak we were all doppelgangers.
我的意思是让你使用他，你说我们都是分身。
Did you did you take Chris's wife's name for Robin Sherbatsky.
你有没有把克里斯妻子的名字改成罗宾·谢尔巴茨基？
So kind of because we moved out to LA and met this incredibly cool new person, Robin, Mergeo, Chris Miller's then fiance or still girlfriend they got married after we went to their wedding.
之所以如此，是因为我们搬到了洛杉矶，遇到了这个非常酷的新朋友，Robin、Mergeo，Chris Miller 当时的未婚夫或仍然是女朋友，他们在我们参加婚礼后就结婚了。
And I remember it helped us want to name the guy.
我记得它帮助我们想给这个人命名。
I think we're talking about the name Robin and then we met like the coolest person in the world named Robin.
我想我们正在谈论罗宾这个名字，然后我们就遇到了世界上最酷的人罗宾。
We're like, yeah, this is a sign from the universe.
我们就像，是的，这是来自宇宙的标志。
So yeah, it influenced it.
所以是的，它影响了它。
That's great.
那太棒了。
Because you were, you were Frankenstein and her together.
因为你是，你就是弗兰肯斯坦和她在一起。
You, is that wasn't based on a real person, right?
你，这不是根据真人改编的吧？
It was the one of the five that was not based on a real person.
这是五个非真人之一。
I want to say that I stole, like, traits from Robin Merge.
我想说我偷了罗宾·合并的特质。
Yeah, but Robin Mergeo doesn't collect guns.
是的，但罗宾·梅吉奥不收集枪支。
She doesn't smoke cigars.
她不抽雪茄。
No five dogs.
没有五只狗。
But there's there's something there and just the good energy.
但那里有一些东西，就是好的能量。
She was like this amazing new person me Matt.
她就像我马特这个了不起的新人。
When we were Deli and we're like, there's some good karma here to put that name in there.
当我们还是熟食店的时候，我们就想，把这个名字放在那里是有一些良好的业力的。
By the way, I have, I have nothing to contribute to this except if we're twisting this thing in on itself even more, how your kids, how you met your kids' mother, if we're going back here, by the way that you met, you met Rebecca in college, is to tell them, tell them how that happened.
顺便说一句，我对此没有什么贡献，除非我们进一步扭曲这件事本身，你的孩子，你如何遇见你孩子的母亲，如果我们回到这里，你在大学遇见丽贝卡的方式，就是告诉他们，告诉他们这是如何发生的。
You've always got to get credit for shit, don't you?
你总是要因为狗屎而获得荣誉，不是吗？
I need to something.
我需要做点什么。
I need to wedge in your way in.
我需要挡住你的路。
Alec Lev, producer extraordinaire, making this whole goddamn podcast, how you were calling this.
亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev），杰出的制作人，制作了这整个该死的播客，你是这么称呼它的。
I guess we're calling this how we met everyone else.
我想我们是这样称呼我们认识其他人的。
So we're having that many seasons away.
所以我们还有那么多赛季。
was my college, dear friend in college, we lived in, I met him right away, freshman year beginning there, and my wife came, had gone to high school with Alec and was a senior skill in high school and came to visit, thinking she might want to go to that school too, and she had been friends with Alec, she said I'll come visit, Alec and a couple other friends, Noah and Joel, and she came and visited them and that is when I met Rebecca, and so I guess you get some sort of credit, it pains me to give you any credit for anything, but I guess, you know what, you know what, I took, I took credit at the wedding, I'm taking it.
是我的大学，亲爱的大学朋友，我们住在那里，我马上就遇到了他，从那里开始了一年级，我的妻子来了，和亚历克一起上高中，在高中是高级技能，来拜访，认为她可能也想去那所学校，她一直是亚历克的朋友，她说我会来拜访，亚历克和其他几个朋友，诺亚和乔尔，她来拜访他们，就在那时我遇到了丽贝卡，所以我想你得到了一些荣誉，让我为任何事情给予你任何荣誉都让我很痛苦，但我想，你知道吗，你知道吗，我在婚礼上获得了荣誉，我正在接受它。
You definitely took credit.
你绝对是占了功劳。
You're meeting Rebecca when you were a college student and she was just visiting, is you're only with a scandal in your whole life.
当你还是一名大学生的时候，你就认识了丽贝卡，而她只是来看望你，你这辈子就只有一次丑闻了。
It is, it was scandalous because she is very smart, besides choosing me as a partner, she's usually very smart and she had skipped a grade in elementary school.
是的，这是可耻的，因为她很聪明，除了选择我作为伴侣之外，她平时也很聪明，小学时就跳级了。
So she was like 16 and a half.
所以她大约16岁半。
I was like 18.
我当时大概18岁。
Jesus.
耶稣。
So I did, it may have, there may be legal ramifications, I shouldn't even be saying this on the air.
所以我这么做了，可能会产生法律后果，我什至不应该在广播中这么说。
Of course, wild meme armature than me at 18 and that is when we met.
当然，狂野的 meme 电枢比我 18 岁，那是我们认识的时候。
When and how we met.
我们何时以及如何相遇。
And yes, I like you.
是的，我喜欢你。
Get some credit.
获得一些信用。
I'm going.
我要去。
I see you guys.
我看到你们了。
Well, let's move back to the episode.
好吧，让我们回到情节。
So Craig, you've talked about the pilot and purple giraffe as kind of being a two-part pilot.
克雷格，你谈到了飞行员和紫色长颈鹿作为一个由两部分组成的飞行员。
It establishes Ted's, you know, deep desire to get married, his kind of obsession and love of Robin.
它确立了泰德对结婚的强烈渴望，以及他对罗宾的痴迷和爱。
How Robin gets folded into the gang.
罗宾如何融入帮派。
We meet Lillian Marshall, they've gotten engaged, Barney is this odd character in their lives who creates all this, I mean, he creates equal parts, great times and troubling times, but they keep him around.
我们遇到了莉莲·马歇尔，他们订婚了，巴尼是他们生活中的一个奇怪的人物，他创造了这一切，我的意思是，他创造了平等的部分，美好的时光和麻烦的时光，但他们把他留在身边。
And in this episode, Chris and Phil came to you and said, we want to do a Barney cartoon.
在这一集中，克里斯和菲尔来找你说，我们想做一部巴尼卡通片。
Like let's explore this character, yeah.
就像让我们探索这个角色一样，是的。
Yeah, there are these animals, they were very much animation guys and they've obviously done a lot more live action to you since then.
是的，有这些动物，他们是动画人员，从那时起他们显然为你做了更多的真人表演。
But they were like, this needs to be the Barney cartoon.
但他们说，这必须是巴尼的卡通片。
This needs to be like, Barney's bugs money and he's just taken us on an adventure.
这需要像巴尼的虫子钱一样，他只是带我们去冒险。
He's just dragging us through insanity.
他只是让我们陷入疯狂。
And they really, I'll give them a lot of credit.
他们真的，我会给他们很大的信任。
They really showed how far you could push Barney and make him just insane.
他们确实展示了你可以把巴尼逼到什么程度，让他发疯。
Like just he does so many insane things.
就像他做了很多疯狂的事情一样。
This is this introduced legendary.
这就是传说中的这个介绍。
This introduced the incredibly tortured sort of like legend wait for it.
这就介绍了令人难以置信的折磨有点像传说等等吧。
Boba, Darry this, this did so many things.
波巴，达里这个，这个做了很多事情。
He's literally at one point inside a suitcase and climbs out of a suitcase, it really is like a lunitian scarting.
他确实曾经在一个手提箱里，然后又从手提箱里爬出来，这真的就像疯子的惊吓。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, I think I mentioned this, but that's the beginning of the master of disguise, right?
我的意思是，我想我提到过这一点，但这就是伪装大师的开始，对吧？
Like the party as like we'll do anything and has done everything, um, the elaborate ploy.
就像党一样，我们会做任何事情，并且已经做了所有事情，嗯，精心策划的策略。
Yeah.
是的。
And they really brought that.
他们确实带来了这一点。
I remember thinking, is it, is it too far?
我记得我当时想，是不是太远了？
Is this too insane?
这也太疯狂了吧？
is Barney in the first two episodes.
前两集中是巴尼。
It's kind of like this needy guy who wants Ted's approval, right?
这有点像这个有需要的人想要得到特德的认可，对吧？
He just wants to be, and he still doesn't this one too.
他只是想成为这样的人，但他仍然没有成为这样的人。
He still constantly wants to, I love how insecure and fragile Barney is underneath the suit.
他仍然不断地想要，我喜欢巴尼在西装下的不安全感和脆弱。
But then you get that in this episode.
但你在这一集中就明白了。
You see Neil climb out of a suitcase and then string this tie and go on with his day, and you're like, yeah, I buy it.
你看到尼尔从手提箱里爬出来，然后系上领带，继续他的一天，你就会说，是的，我买了它。
I buy it.
我买它。
There's something about Neil's commitment that you buy it.
尼尔的承诺是让你买下它。
And then he says, believe it or not, that worked.
然后他说，不管你信不信，这确实有效。
And I wish, I wish I could remember, I'm sure we had some backstory of what he was saying to that woman to explain why he had been in the suitcase.
我希望，我希望我能记得，我确信我们有一些他对那个女人所说的话的背景故事，以解释他为什么在手提箱里。
But Neil also, like, he is a magician, he, he, he's literally, like, he was the head of the magic castle for years, like he loves trickery and he loves an elaborate ploy.
但尼尔也，就像，他是一个魔术师，他，他，他确实，就像，他多年来一直是魔法城堡的负责人，就像他喜欢诡计，他喜欢精心设计的策略。
And I think so much of the way he played Barney was this magic trick, right?
我认为他扮演巴尼的方式很大程度上就是这个魔术，对吧？
Like the whole character was a kind of, um, you thought you were watching one thing.
就像整个角色是一种，嗯，你以为你在看一件事。
It was always something kind of something else.
它总是某种别的东西。
It was a really kind of elaborately stacked deck the way he played it.
从他的打法来看，这确实是一副精心堆叠的牌组。
He was.
他是。
You always fall to him.
你总是沦陷在他的身边。
There was something else underneath that suit.
这套衣服下面还有别的东西。
There was something he was going to pull out.
他有东西要拿出来。
My favorite thing of what's underneath that suit is just how neat he is.
我最喜欢那套西装下面的东西就是他的整洁。
Even in this episode, he's like Ted, he's trying to phone five Ted and he's like Ted, I know when you don't phone five.
即使在这一集里，他也像泰德一样，他试图给五个泰德打电话，而他就像泰德，我知道你什么时候不给五个电话。
And he's so attuned to wanting Ted's approval.
他非常渴望得到特德的认可。
Even in this one where he's just dragged, he's just giving him this horrible night.
即使在他只是被拖着的这个地方，他也只是给了他这个可怕的夜晚。
It's also funny that he's clearly coining things in like he's done him like twice, but he's declared it's a thing.
同样有趣的是，他显然是在创造一些东西，就像他已经做过两次一样，但他宣称这是一件事。
Like this is the thing we do.
就像这就是我们所做的事情。
But like, no one's ever participated before, but he's like, this is our thing.
但就像，以前没有人参与过，但他就像，这是我们的事。
Do it, you know?
做吧，你知道吗？
Yeah, I feel like there's a chance that was the first phone five and he's actually like, they do it all the time.
是的，我觉得有可能是第一个电话五，他实际上就像，他们一直这样做。
Yeah.
是的。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，HyperFixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radio Topia.
这是来自 Radio Topia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
I know, backs the show.
我知道，支持这个节目。
He just wants to belong.
他只是想要归属感。
He's so badly wants to belong.
他非常想要归属。
That's what I got from these early Barney episodes.
这就是我从巴尼早期剧集中得到的信息。
And maybe we lost our way at certain points later where we made him too literally the thing.
也许后来我们在某些时候迷失了方向，我们把他塑造得太真实了。
But what I really love about these early ones is he's just so fragile and needy.
但我真正喜欢这些早期的人的是他是如此脆弱和需要帮助。
And I think it gives Ted such power in the episode.
我认为这赋予了特德在这一集中如此强大的力量。
But it's also power Ted never asked for.
但这也是特德从未要求过的权力。
Now it's power that was thrust in Ted's laugh.
现在，特德的笑声中注入了力量。
And he's like, man, I don't want to be the guardian of your self-esteem.
他说，伙计，我不想成为你自尊的守护者。
Like, I can't be like always telling you, you know, affirming you and going on these adventures.
就像，我不能总是告诉你，你知道，肯定你并继续这些冒险。
But okay, so talking through the plot, like how, what was your kind of initial inspiration for this beyond a cartoon?
但是好吧，那么通过情节来谈谈，比如，除了卡通之外，你最初的灵感是什么？
The episode, the two questions of this episode, I remember talking about in the Reders Room, where why are they friends with this insane guy who wears suits and just like says in saying things and doesn't say, how do we make the sale of why Barney's their friend?
这一集，这一集的两个问题，我记得在红人房间里谈论过，他们为什么和这个穿着西装的疯狂家伙成为朋友，就像在说事情时说的那样，但没有说，我们如何解释为什么巴尼是他们的朋友？
And then the other thing we're trying to make the sale on was showing Robin and Lily becoming friends.
我们试图推销的另一件事是展示罗宾和莉莉成为朋友。
Like, they really just met Robin.
就像，他们真的刚刚认识罗宾。
They don't have a dynamic, you know?
他们没有动力，你知道吗？
Like, Barney has been with them for years.
就像，巴尼已经和他们在一起很多年了。
Like, I think he does invent things and pretend that they always do it.
就像，我认为他确实发明了一些东西，并假装他们总是这样做。
I love that observation, Josh.
我喜欢这个观察，乔什。
But I think, like, they have history.
但我认为，他们有历史。
Robin and Lily, we just got to get them together and show them having a cute, fun night at the bar.
罗宾和莉莉，我们只需要把他们聚在一起，让他们在酒吧度过一个可爱、有趣的夜晚。
Those were the two missions.
这是两个任务。
And we wanted to end an episode that says, why does Barney add value to this group?
我们想在这一集的结尾说，为什么巴尼为这个团队增加了价值？
And making the sale to the audience of like, Okay, the first two episodes were really heartfelt.
并向观众推销，好吧，前两集真的很真诚。
It was really Ted Hart forward those first two episodes.
前两集确实是泰德·哈特（Ted Hart）转发的。
I loved how they felt like an hour.
我喜欢他们一个小时的感觉。
I feel like you could just watch that as an hour.
我觉得你可以看一个小时。
Those first two ones, and it felt that way much more than I remember it showing that way at the time.
前两个，这种感觉比我记忆中当时表现的要强烈得多。
The third one, this one is just like, we're just gonna try something different.
第三个，这个就像，我们只是要尝试一些不同的东西。
This is just gonna be a different kind of song.
这将是一首不同类型的歌曲。
And it had to make the sale of like, Barney, you're gonna wanna watch Barney, he's gonna bring you crazy places you never would've gone.
它必须让你喜欢巴尼，你会想看巴尼，他会给你带来你永远不会去的疯狂地方。
Yeah.
是的。
And I like the generosity at the end of Sagitt, Sagitt's voiceover is really nice at the end of, And that's why we hung out with Barney.
我喜欢萨吉特结尾处的慷慨，萨吉特结尾的画外音真的很好，这就是我们和巴尼一起出去玩的原因。
You wound up somewhere.
你最终在某个地方。
You never would have been.
你永远不会。
You wound up with the story.
你结束了这个故事。
And the proof is that he's telling the kids that story.
证据就是他正在给孩子们讲这个故事。
It's the night they went to lick the liberty belt.
那天晚上他们去舔自由腰带。
It's the night they did that.
那天晚上他们就这么做了。
And Barney's always looking for these superlatives in this kind of damaged, searching, needy, strange way, needing to feel superlative and special.
巴尼总是以这种受损、探索、匮乏、奇怪的方式寻找这些最高级的东西，需要感觉最高级和特别。
And it's also a real, he's addicted to novelty.
而且这也是真的，他对新奇事物上瘾了。
He wants to be the first one to do something.
他想成为第一个做某事的人。
wants to create these stories, no one's ever done this before.
想要创造这些故事，以前没有人这样做过。
And also his inability to commit and always having to be with a new woman is like this kind of rotating.
而他无法做出承诺，总是不得不和一个新女人在一起，就像这种轮换。
It's this is a dopamine search, you know, he's a different like the dopamine hit of the new.
这是一次多巴胺搜索，你知道，他与新的多巴胺打击不同。
But and yet monogamously committed to Ted.
但仍然对泰德一夫一妻制。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
It's his greatest relationship.
这是他最大的关系。
It's his greatest love.
这是他最大的爱。
It's his greatest, it's his greatest and longest relationship.
这是他最伟大、最伟大、最长的关系。
And it's like genuinely sweet.
这就像真正的甜蜜。
He's a needy.
他是一个有需要的人。
Ted has the upper hand in that relationship in a lot of ways.
泰德在这段关系中在很多方面都占据上风。
Ted is dragged through this insanity.
特德被这种疯狂所拖累。
He winds up, you know, detained by like TSA.
你知道，他最终被美国运输安全管理局 (TSA) 等机构拘留。
I mean, Ted has a bad night of it.
我的意思是，特德度过了一个糟糕的夜晚。
But in the end, he looks back fondly.
但最终，他满怀深情地回望。
But Josh, remember you were saying watching it.
但是乔什，记住你说的是观看它。
You were like, I wish there were a couple more moments where we had Ted either in the writing or the playing of it or both where we had Ted enjoying it more, being like, like a few more little moments where Ted's like, all right, yeah, this is kind of fun.
你说，我希望有更多的时刻，让泰德在写作或演奏中，或者两者兼而有之，让泰德更享受它，就像，就像，还有一些小时刻，泰德会说，好吧，是的，这很有趣。
Which I guess fights against the ending of the ending is when when he realizes that, but yeah, I know what you mean.
我想当他意识到这一点时，就会与结局的结局相抗衡，但是，是的，我知道你的意思。
That was, you made that observation when we were talking about it before.
就是说，您在我们之前讨论的时候也说过这样的话。
That's similar about that.
这点与此类似。
Like, do you feel like?
比如说，你有这样的感觉吗？
Yeah, I mean, when I was watching it, so the first two episodes, Ted is not only heart-forward but he's like, plot-forward.
是的，我的意思是，当我看的时候，所以前两集，泰德不仅是内心的前向，而且他的情节也很前向。
He's the engine of the plot.
他是剧情的引擎。
The motor.
电机。
Everyone is kind of reacting around his mania and his drive and his passion.
每个人都会围绕他的狂热、他的动力和他的激情做出反应。
And I found that was very easy to play.
我发现这很容易玩。
I understood how to play that.
我明白怎么玩了。
In this episode, I think I misjudged it Like if I could go back and adjust the dial, I would have found it, Barney's the driver of this episode.
在这一集中，我想我误判了它就像如果我可以回去调整表盘，我就会找到它，巴尼是这一集的司机。
I will say this, I have such a strong memory and these little things stick out at you when we were on the New York street, I'm walking Ted's walking with Marshall and Lily and Barney pulls up in the cab, right?
我要说的是，我的记忆力很强，当我们在纽约街上时，这些小事对你来说很突出，我正在散步，泰德和马歇尔、莉莉一起散步，巴尼把车停在出租车里，对吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And he's like, get in, right?
他说，进来吧？
Yeah.
是的。
I remember there was a look in Neil's eyes that I will never forget.
我记得尼尔的眼神让我永远不会忘记。
And it was like, he had dropped into a new level of barniness.
就好像，他已经陷入了一个新的疯狂状态。
Yeah, yes.
是的，是的。
There's a hundred percent of what I'm talking about, the energy, yeah, I think that's Christian.
我所说的有百分之一百的能量，是的，我认为这就是基督教。
And it also looked like I'm taking this episode.
看起来我也正在拍摄这一集。
Yeah.
是的。
Like I'm taking it.
就像我正在接受它一样。
I'm taking it.
我接受了。
And I felt a little bit like I was just along for the ride.
我感觉有点像我只是随波逐流。
Now, the fun parts of it for me and Ed.
现在，对我和艾德来说，其中有趣的部分。
Well, it's literally a hostage situation.
好吧，这实际上是一个人质事件。
It is.
这是。
That's right.
这是正确的。
Like he has such a deep relationship already with the cab driver.
好像他和出租车司机的关系已经很深了。
With the cab driver.
和出租车司机一起。
Yeah.
是的。
That is based on, we always had a friend who always like very much got the cab driver's name and would always have like, that's a ranger, like it was, it was a friend of ours.
这是基于，我们总是有一个朋友，他总是非常喜欢知道出租车司机的名字，并且总是喜欢，那是一个护林员，就像它是我们的一个朋友一样。
Right.
正确的。
And a letterman writer would always do that and sort of take over the cab in a way like Buzz of Burgers.
莱特曼作家总是会这样做，并以像《汉堡的嗡嗡声》那样的方式接管出租车。
I don't know how Esteban can, it's a little creepy to contemplate.
我不知道埃斯特班是怎么做到的，想想就有点令人毛骨悚然。
How can Esteban lock Ted in?
埃斯特班怎样才能把泰德锁起来？
I don't want to think about that, but I, but what I, what I liked about it, especially in the interrogation scene, which is kind of a classic him, you know, that is a great scene.
我不想去想这个，但是我，但是我，我喜欢它，特别是在审讯场景中，这是一个经典的他，你知道，那是一个很棒的场景。
is so funny.
太搞笑了。
The security guard is so funny.
保安太搞笑了
The main guy is so funny.
男主角太搞笑了
But what I felt was at its best, it establishes Ted and Barney as a kind of Abbott and Costello Laurel and Hardy, like a classic Vodville team, where you have the crazy one and then you have the eye roller, right?
但我觉得最好的情况是，它把泰德和巴尼塑造成一种雅培和科斯特罗劳雷尔和哈代，就像一支经典的沃德维尔球队，你有疯狂的，然后你有眼球滚动的，对吧？
Yeah, and that was your job in this one.
是的，这就是你的工作。
You have to be the straight man, which is arguably the most important part of the equation.
你必须是一个正直的人，这可以说是这个等式中最重要的部分。
It's called in the hard stocks of that guy.
那家伙的硬股票里就叫这个。
This is why I'll always He's loved Mike Sure, who created many classic television shows, Parks and Rec and Brooklyn 99.
这就是为什么我永远喜欢迈克·苏尔（Mike Sure），他创作了许多经典电视节目《公园与休闲》（Parks and Rec）和《布鲁克林 99》（Brooklyn 99）。
And they're all brilliant shows, but he wrote a piece after Harold Raimus died.
这些都是精彩的表演，但他在哈罗德·雷姆斯去世后写了一篇文章。
Yeah.
是的。
I think Esquire about how there's no Bill Murray without a Harold Raimus.
我认为 Esquire 认为没有哈罗德·雷姆斯就没有比尔·默里。
A hundred percent.
百分之一百。
Like you can.
就像你可以的那样。
I mean, in Ghostbusters, Egon is like that movie in so many ways, like, like, and how brilliant he was at, like, holding down the center, so the crazy person can be crazy.
我的意思是，在《捉鬼敢死队》中，埃贡在很多方面都像那部电影一样，他在控制中心方面非常出色，所以疯狂的人可能会疯狂。
Yes.
是的。
And that's hard.
这很难。
That was your job.
那是你的工作。
Really hard.
真的很难。
And I feel like the, like I ran into a metaparty and I told him, I was like, I just felt so seen by that article because that's what I had to do on how I made my mother.
我觉得，就像我遇到了一个元派对，我告诉他，我觉得，我只是觉得那篇文章让我很受关注，因为这就是我在塑造我母亲时必须做的事情。
And he said to me, he goes, well, he goes, you and John Krasinski and Adam Scott will never win Emmys for these shows, but these shows cannot work without you.
他对我说，他走了，好吧，他走了，你和约翰·卡拉辛斯基和亚当·斯科特永远不会因为这些节目赢得艾美奖，但这些节目没有你就无法运作。
But there's no show without that role.
但没有这个角色就没有演出。
There's no show.
没戏了
But in some ways, I just wish, because I was, I was placed, I, the first two episodes I was so active.
但从某些方面来说，我只是希望，因为我是，我是被安置的，我，前两集我这么活跃。
And in this one, I was basically reactive.
在这一次，我基本上是被动的。
Yeah.
是的。
And I wish that there had been some softening of my response to it.
我希望我对此的反应能有所软化。
That said, he does have to blow up at him.
话虽这么说，他确实得对他发脾气。
He does get annoyed, you know, so I know what you mean.
你知道，他确实很生气，所以我明白你的意思。
I know what you mean.
我知道你的意思。
I think it's already hitting something a little hard.
我认为它已经碰到了一些困难。
But I think it's brilliantly constructed the episode, you know, it's really constructed to do what you wanted to do.
但我认为这一集的构建非常出色，你知道，它确实是为了做你想做的事情而构建的。
And I also think one more thing, I realize I'm on a tear here.
我还想到一件事，我意识到我在这里热泪盈眶。
You're still teaching the audience how to watch how I met your mother, and you're also teaching yourself what the show is and what it's capable of.
你还在教观众如何观看我是如何遇见你母亲的，你也在教自己这个节目是什么以及它的能力。
Yes.
是的。
Right.
正确的。
In terms of three.
就三而言。
So you have this pattern established, this, you know, what do they say?
所以你已经建立了这个模式，你知道，他们怎么说？
There's like 17 plots or something like, like the first one is one plot essentially.
大概有 17 个情节或类似的东西，就像第一个情节本质上是一个情节。
That seems high.
看来这个很高啊
I think there's like five.
我想大概有五个吧
Maybe there's five plus.
也许还有五个以上。
The second one is, no, no, we can also do this.
第二个是，不不，我们也可以这样做。
It's like a superhero discovering another power.
这就像超级英雄发现了另一种力量。
We can also let Barney be an insane engine of mania and wild ideas.
我们还可以让巴尼成为狂热和疯狂想法的疯狂引擎。
The show is auditioning to the audience still in this episode.
该节目仍在本集中向观众试镜。
All of season one is auditioning.
第一季全部都是试镜。
What other moves do we have?
我们还有哪些举措？
We showed you the TED, essentially an hour long, like TED, heartfelt story.
我们向您展示了 TED，基本上长达一个小时，就像 TED 一样，是一个发自内心的故事。
And now, this next one, which almost feels like episode two, the more I talk about it, because I keep on thinking of the first one as an hour.
现在，下一个几乎感觉像是第二集，我谈论得越多，因为我一直认为第一集是一个小时。
This had to show a new move, this had to show a new move, and how did you show the two ladies together?
这必须表现出新的动作，这必须表现出新的动作，你是怎么表现出这两位女士在一起的？
We needed that.
我们需要那个。
We needed them to become friends.
我们需要他们成为朋友。
And I liked them together.
我喜欢他们在一起。
I will say, while we're expressing mild regrets, I liked that story.
我想说，虽然我们表达了轻微的遗憾，但我喜欢这个故事。
I think they were cute together.
我觉得他们在一起很可爱。
I think I actually set up some good things of Lily, like wrestling with, like, oh, I'm engaged lady now, and that sort of plants a little bit of a seed for later in the season, spoilers, things that might happen about her attitude towards am I getting married to young.
我想我实际上为莉莉设定了一些好的东西，比如摔跤，比如，哦，我现在订婚了，女士，这种为本季晚些时候播下一点种子，剧透，她对我和年轻人结婚的态度可能会发生的事情。
It's like, there's a little seed planted there, but I will say when I watch this one, it's a very sort of linear that story between her and Robin.
就像，那里种下了一点种子，但我会说，当我观看这个时，这是她和罗宾之间的一个非常线性的故事。
It's very much like it could be another sitcom.
这很像是另一部情景喜剧。
Do you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
It's like they're in the bar.
就好像他们在酒吧里一样。
There's sort of a series of beats we don't play with time that much.
有一系列的节拍我们不怎么玩弄时间。
It's fun at the end how the two stories kind of dovetail Marshall comes in.
有趣的是，最后这两个故事是如何吻合的，马歇尔的出现。
Thanks the guys hitting on her.
谢谢那些打她的人。
There's things I like about it and I just like them.
有些事情我很喜欢，而且我就是喜欢它们。
It was the right move to put those two ladies together.
将这两位女士放在一起是正确的举动。
But from a writing perspective, I watched it and I thought, boy, the Barney story is this very fun cartoon.
但从写作的角度来看，我看了它，我想，男孩，巴尼的故事是一部非常有趣的动画片。
There's three way split screens.
有三路分屏。
There's intercuts, Marshall's driving, Marshall's singing crazy songs.
有插播，马歇尔开车，马歇尔唱着疯狂的歌曲。
Barney's climbing out of suitcases.
巴尼正从手提箱里爬出来。
There's high, high angle security camera, black and white footage.
有高、高角度的安全摄像头、黑白镜头。
And there's like, you're just in this world.
就像，你就在这个世界上。
And then you go to the bar and it's all kind of linear.
然后你去酒吧，一切都是线性的。
And maybe that's okay.
也许没关系。
And they offset each other.
并且它们相互抵消。
But I remember feeling like, this isn't as him, you me, this B story, this Lily, Robin B story.
但我记得当时的感觉是，这不是他、你、我，这个 B 故事，这个莉莉、罗宾 B 的故事。
I remember feeling like maybe that's the sign of early times where we didn't quite figure out a way within that linear story to kind of make it work.
我记得我感觉这可能是早期的迹象，我们在线性故事中还没有找到一种让它发挥作用的方法。
But I will say it felt psychologically honest to me.
但我想说的是，这对我来说在心理上是诚实的。
Yeah.
是的。
In that, Lily is reckoning with this feeling that a phase of her life is done, like going to a bar and spotting a guy across the room and him coming over and talking like she's not going to have that anymore.
莉莉正在考虑这种感觉，她生命中的某个阶段已经结束了，就像去一家酒吧，发现房间对面有一个男人，他走过来说话，好像她不会再有这样的事情了。
And Robin seems to have that just endless in the episode.
罗宾在这一集中似乎有无穷无尽的东西。
But I really like what Robin says, you know, you have what we're all here looking around.
但我真的很喜欢罗宾所说的，你知道，你拥有我们都在这里环顾四周的东西。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
That's what made it land.
这就是它落地的原因。
And that's what made me feel like they were friends.
这就是让我觉得他们是朋友的原因。
I feel like we made the sale.
我觉得我们成功了。
That was, I love that moment.
那就是，我喜欢那一刻。
I love how she says that, Joe.
我喜欢她这么说，乔。
Everybody here is looking for what you already got.
这里的每个人都在寻找你已经拥有的东西。
Yeah.
是的。
And that's that's tonight.
今晚就是这样。
That's And also the our favorite girl in the pilot who says what's taken so like you get the feeling like Robin just hadn't found her tribe in New York and suddenly it's not just Ted it's like oh this is a girlfriend there's like this is a new good deep girlfriend who I can talk with I can be honest with like you really do need to establish that and I think it was well done.
这也是飞行员中我们最喜欢的女孩，她说了什么，所以你会感觉罗宾刚刚在纽约找不到她的部落，突然间，不仅仅是泰德，这就像哦，这是一个女朋友，这是一个新的好女朋友，我可以和她交谈，我可以诚实地告诉她，就像你确实需要建立这一点，我认为做得很好。
What I loved about the end of purple giraffe episode two is Ted invites, Ted knows he's got this treasure chest full of wonderful humans that he can offer to Robin if he can only get over his own feeling that he's been rejected by her.
我喜欢紫色长颈鹿第二集结尾的是泰德的邀请，泰德知道他有一个装满了精彩人类的宝箱，如果他能克服自己被罗宾拒绝的感觉，他可以将这些宝箱提供给罗宾。
If he can be generous enough to say, come, you need a tribe, I've got one, I've got it for you.
如果他能足够慷慨地说，来吧，你需要一个部落，我有一个，我已经为你准备好了。
I can cast your life with a set of amazing friends and he's generous enough to do that at the end of purple giraffe.
我可以让你的生活与一群很棒的朋友在一起，他足够慷慨，在紫色长颈鹿的最后做到了这一点。
And then we see the gift of that and the fact that the Lee and Robin bond And the fact that Robin sort of talks Willie down and says, like, don't be insane.
然后我们看到了这一点的天赋，以及李和罗宾之间的关系，以及罗宾对威利的劝说，比如，别疯了。
You have what these people are looking for.
您拥有这些人正在寻找的东西。
I love that ending.
我喜欢那个结局。
Yeah, I just felt like it was a little linear along the way.
是的，我只是觉得一路上有点线性。
I was like, how, especially we found a little like bell and or whistle along the way in that storyline, I could have been a little more fun.
我当时想，特别是我们在故事情节中发现了一点像铃声或口哨声的东西，我本来可以更有趣一点。
But I like plenty of it.
但我喜欢很多。
And I really like how it ends.
我真的很喜欢它的结局。
And also, Marshall and Lily, especially in the first season, they're metabolizing going first.
而且，马歇尔和莉莉，尤其是在第一季，他们首先新陈代谢。
They are.
他们是。
They're metabolizing where the ones who are doing this first.
他们正在新陈代谢，而那些最先这样做的人也在新陈代谢。
We don't have any contemporaries that we can turn to and be like, yeah, what was it like in your first month of engagement?
我们没有可以求助的同龄人，我们会问，是的，你订婚的第一个月感觉如何？
Like, what was it like when you realized you were wedding ring repelled men in a bar or whatever, you know?
就像，当你意识到你在酒吧或其他地方被结婚戒指排斥的男人时，你知道吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And this was, this was Rebecca and I, we were the young old married couple.
这是，这是丽贝卡和我，我们是年轻的老夫妇。
That's what we were.
我们就是这样。
And we went through all of that and felt separate from our friends in some ways.
我们经历了这一切，并在某些方面感到与我们的朋友分离。
Like, the thing where Marshall is home alone studying law, like that sort of me talking of like Carter and all the wait show writers, they're out doing crazy stuff.
就像马歇尔独自在家学习法律的事情，就像我所说的卡特和所有等待节目的编剧一样，他们出去做了疯狂的事情。
I'm in crazy stories.
我陷入了疯狂的故事中。
And I'm like at a bed and breakfast in Connecticut with my wife, like with other like 60 year olds.
我就像和我的妻子一起在康涅狄格州的一家住宿加早餐酒店，就像和其他 60 岁的人一样。
And we were old before our time.
而我们却提前老了。
I mean, it was, it was fun to be old before our time.
我的意思是，在我们这个时代之前变老是很有趣的。
I was fine with that.
我对此很满意。
Every now and again, I was like, uh, shit, I wish I could just go get in the car and drive and like go be in Atlantic City with those guys or whatever.
时不时地，我会想，呃，该死，我希望我能上车开车，然后和那些家伙一起去大西洋城什么的。
It's like an adventure they're all having.
这就像他们都在经历一场冒险。
I'd be seeing this game from speaking of Marshall home alone studying.
我是从谈到马歇尔独自在家学习时才看到这场比赛的。
Um, this was for, this was Marshall's singing first.
嗯，这是为了，这是马歇尔先唱歌的。
It was the debut of Marshall.
这是马歇尔的首次亮相。
It's almost a musical episode.
这几乎是一个音乐剧。
It's almost like a mind a low-key musical episode because like 40% of his dialogue is song.
这几乎就像是一部低调的音乐剧，因为他的对话中有 40% 是歌曲。
I love it so much.
我非常喜欢它。
I should say that I don't recall you or Carter unless it was like a big number like you've got slapped or whatever.
我应该说，我不记得你或卡特，除非是一个很大的数字，比如你被扇了一巴掌或者其他什么。
Did he write you've got slapped or you guys wrote it?
是他写的，还是你们写的？
We wrote that.
我们这样写的。
You wrote that.
你写的。
Yeah.
是的。
But the other like.
但其他的都喜欢。
No, he did the melodies.
不，他创作了旋律。
He did all the abilities.
所有的能力他都做到了。
He came up with this.
他想出了这个。
Yeah, he will never unhere.
是的，他永远不会离开这里。
We are not loyal.
我们不忠诚。
And we hear all the time on social media from lawyers and law students who say like, I say that five times a day.
我们经常在社交媒体上听到律师和法学院学生说，我每天都会说五次。
Like they like like lawyers and training very much.
就像他们非常喜欢律师和培训一样。
What's the other line?
另一条线是什么？
Like something responsible choice for making a responsible choice for my future.
就像一些负责任的选择，为我的未来做出负责任的选择。
And by the way, that was another like were auditioning the character because Marshall and those first couples kind of like he has to propose.
顺便说一句，这又是一次试镜，因为马歇尔和第一对夫妇就像他必须求婚一样。
He has to be that guy has to be like the nervous guy trying to move on to a more adult chapter of life.
他必须是那种紧张的人，试图进入更成熟的人生篇章。
And this one Marshall got to show that he's this fun weirdo.
马歇尔必须证明他是一个有趣的怪人。
He's this absolute fun weirdo.
他是个绝对有趣的怪人。
He's trying to study.
他正在努力学习。
He's he's missing out on great times with his friends and he is singing himself like a crazy person alone in the apartment and there's something so charming about it.
他错过了与朋友们一起度过的美好时光，他独自一人在公寓里像个疯子一样唱歌，这真是太迷人了。
Seagull killed that stuff.
海鸥杀死了那东西。
Marshall has a little bit of a like puppy energy.
马歇尔有一点像小狗的能量。
Like he, we, if someone throws a ball, he goes after it.
就像他，我们一样，如果有人扔球，他就会去追球。
He does.
他做到了。
Like come to Philly.
就像来到费城一样。
Okay.
好的。
I know.
我知道。
Don't you go back.
你别回去。
Okay.
好的。
Like he's like tearing around.
就像他在撕扯一样。
Yeah.
是的。
He really, um, he's up for, he even though he's, you know, engaged and he's trying to be, you know, be responsible.
他真的，嗯，他已经准备好了，尽管他，你知道，订婚了，他正在努力，你知道，负责任。
He's still like up for a good time.
他仍然很高兴。
Yeah.
是的。
Totally.
完全。
Yeah.
是的。
There's some very, I love all the christened philisms in here because they, they make those little songs from Marshall.
我非常喜欢这里所有所谓的非理性，因为他们创作了马歇尔的那些小歌。
I feel like that was very much Chris and Phil.
我觉得这就是克里斯和菲尔的风格。
Like that's just, there's certain things that are just very uniquely.
就像那样，有些东西是非常独特的。
It's only how they would say them.
这只是他们会怎么说的。
Like one of those songs, it's, and it's an act break.
就像其中一首歌一样，它是一个表演休息。
And they say act to break.
他们说采取行动来打破。
Marshall's singing a little song at the end of back two because he's going and turning around now.
马歇尔在第二场比赛结束时唱了一首小歌，因为他现在要转身。
He's turned around from Philly and I was turning around to go back to Philly.
他从费城转机，而我则转身返回费城。
And he just ends his song by saying, destroy.
他以“毁灭”结束了他的歌曲。
And it's just so weird going to Philly.
去费城真是太奇怪了。
Destroy.
破坏。
It's just like so bizarre.
简直太奇怪了。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
I think that was very Chris and Phil.
我认为这就是克里斯和菲尔的风格。
And so like, if you look at Barney's dialogue in this episode, he's so fucking crazy in this episode.
就像，如果你看巴尼在这一集中的对话，他在这一集中真是太疯狂了。
And the way he speaks isn't saying, he's short, little staccato burst, he's just trying, everything is him trying to brand a new phrase, like you were saying, whether or not they've ever said it, you don't know if he's ever said this to them before, he's just pretending they say it all the time.
他说话的方式并不是说，他很短，断断续续，他只是在尝试，一切都是他试图创造一个新的短语，就像你说的，无论他们是否曾经说过，你不知道他以前是否对他们说过这样的话，他只是假装他们一直在说。
But he commits to, I mean, talk about committing to the bit.
但他承诺，我的意思是，谈论承诺这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
I like the, the, this, the phone, the phone, the, the phone, the, the phone, the, the phone eyes, the phone eyes, the two fingers, the two fingers, those three photos, like the, the pointing to his eyes, pointing to you, pointing to his eyes, that little three photo montage, also a chrysanthemum joke that, so sometimes as a showrunner, you get a script into you, and you have this weird response where there's so many good things that you're happy because you know the rewrite's not gonna be very extensive, but you're also like a little bit jealous, like fuck.
我喜欢这个，那个，这个，电话，电话，那个，电话，那个，电话，那个，电话的眼睛，电话的眼睛，两个手指，两个手指，那三张照片，就像，指着他的眼睛，指着你，指着他的眼睛，那个小三张照片蒙太奇，也是一个菊花笑话，所以有时作为一个节目主持人，你会得到一个剧本，你会有这种奇怪的反应，其中有很多好东西你很高兴，因为你知道重写不会很广泛，但你也有点嫉妒，就像他妈的。
I wish I thought of that.
我希望我能想到这一点。
Or like, that's better than I, than I could write.
或者说，这比我更好，比我能写的更好。
And like those guys, chrysanthemums, there's so many things in there that are like, you know, the lactose intolerant legendary joke, That's a christened full classic.
就像那些家伙，菊花，里面有很多东西，就像，你知道的，乳糖不耐症的传奇笑话，那是一个完整的经典。
It's very funny after the show ended like 10 years out.
这部剧结束十年后，这很有趣。
Sometime recently we got a call from Entertainment Weekly, Carter and I did.
最近的某个时候，我们接到了《娱乐周刊》的电话，卡特和我接到了。
They're like, we wanted to talk to you guys as show owners of how much your mother, we're doing this like top 50 best TV catchphrases or best lines on a series.
他们就像，我们想和你们这些节目主持人谈谈你们的母亲，我们在做这件事，就像前 50 名最佳电视流行语或电视剧中的最佳台词一样。
And I'm like, oh, don't mind if I do.
我想，哦，如果我这样做的话，不要介意。
That's straight in my tie here.
就在我的领带上。
Maybe they'll put a photo of us.
也许他们会贴一张我们的照片。
I wonder which one of our gyms that we wrote Entertainment Weekly wants to highlight.
我想知道我们写的《娱乐周刊》想要重点介绍哪一家健身房。
And I'm like, yeah, we already talked to christened Phil because it's their line, but we just want a little background from you too.
我想，是的，我们已经和受洗的菲尔谈过了，因为这是他们的台词，但我们也只是想从你那里了解一些背景知识。
And we're like, how do you want to hire Chris and Phil?
我们问，你想如何雇用克里斯和菲尔？
So you and Carter, obviously, were the main writers on the first two episodes.
显然，你和卡特是前两集的主要编剧。
Yeah.
是的。
And then you get this, you get a writer, you get a writer's room together like, how much did you crack the story of the sweet taste of liberty and then hand it to Chris and Phil?
然后你得到这个，你得到一个作家，你得到一个作家的房间，就像，你破解了多少自由的甜蜜味道的故事，然后把它交给克里斯和菲尔？
Or did they say, let's write a Barney cartoon and they came back with that?
或者他们说，让我们写一部巴尼漫画，然后他们就回来了？
They were part of cracking it, but they were a very strong voice of Barney cartoon.
他们是破解这个问题的一部分，但他们是巴尼卡通的一个非常强烈的声音。
We did this hour long, rom-com, very sweet, very heartfelt.
我们做了一个小时的浪漫喜剧，非常甜蜜，非常衷心。
Now we need to be.
现在我们需要这样做。
to take over and make it like a fun cartoon and that idea of going to the airport, I got to pick someone up at the airport, the security cam montage, the fact that they're getting on airplanes, they had a great like bravado and fearlessness to like let's just take swings.
接手并把它变成一个有趣的卡通片和去机场的想法，我必须去机场接一个人，安全摄像头蒙太奇，他们正在上飞机的事实，他们有一种伟大的虚张声势和无所畏惧，就像让我们来挥杆一样。
And I just think that comes from that animation brain incentive in some way.
我只是认为这在某种程度上来自于动画大脑的激励。
So did you guys, did the writers room come up with like picking up girls at the airport, picking someone up at the airport, like going to Philly with those girls and finding out they'd date Philadelphia Eagles or whatever.
你们也是，编剧室有没有想出像在机场接女孩，在机场接某人，比如和那些女孩一起去费城，发现她们会和费城老鹰队约会之类的。
I think it was one thing led to another.
我认为这是一件事导致了另一件事。
I think we had the pun of picking up somebody at the airport.
我想我们有去机场接人的双关语。
We liked that and that brought us to the airport.
我们很喜欢这个，这就把我们带到了机场。
And you just keep yes ending it.
然后你就继续说“是”就结束了。
Then it became like, what if they do wind up on a plane and flying to a different city and like just pushing it and pushing it and pushing it and I feel like those guys were very good at like, don't be afraid.
然后就变成了，如果他们最终坐上了飞机，飞往另一个城市，就像只是推动它，推动它，推动它，我觉得那些人非常擅长，不要害怕。
This one's going to be a road trip movie.
这将是一部公路旅行电影。
We're just just going to do it.
我们只是要做而已。
They're just, and I have that idea of having a licking the Liberty Bell.
他们只是，我有舔自由钟的想法。
I'm like, we have to make it a legendary night.
我想，我们必须让它成为一个传奇之夜。
A lot of that was from, from Chris and Phil.
其中很多来自克里斯和菲尔。
And I'm forever grateful for it because it did help deepen and define Barney.
我永远感激它，因为它确实帮助加深和定义了巴尼。
And it showed you like some of these episodes are just going to be like a crazy trip to the circus.
它向你展示了其中一些剧集就像一次疯狂的马戏团之旅。
Like they're not all going to be like super felt ever ever writing question.
就像他们不会都像曾经写过的问题一样超级有感觉。
Obviously it's season one.
显然这是第一季。
So everything you're doing is defining future characters.
所以你所做的一切都是在定义未来的角色。
But you know, You know, on other, on even the shows we loved on, on, on, on mash on chairs, plots didn't, um, threaten to redefine characters, right, even from episode one, everyone sort of set.
但你知道，你知道，在其他方面，即使是我们喜欢的节目，在椅子上的混搭，情节并没有，嗯，威胁要重新定义角色，对吧，即使从第一集开始，每个人都有点设定。
And then it's like, what, what high jinks are they getting into?
然后就好像，什么，他们正在搞什么恶作剧？
But you've got to make big decisions because you have, you have an end game in sight.
但你必须做出重大决定，因为你已经看到了结局。
And you've also decided this is going to be a different kind of show.
你也决定这将是一场不同类型的演出。
you start off with ultimate Ted Romantic looking for the one and kind of maybe finds it.
你从终极泰德浪漫开始寻找那个人，也许会找到它。
And now you have to, I don't know, you're going to switch to Ted's going to start dating the co-check girl, the crossing guard.
现在你必须，我不知道，你要切换到泰德要开始和副检查女孩，路口警卫约会。
You're going to send Ted off on smaller adventures and what goes into your far-thinking mind as you're writing these early plots.
当你写这些早期情节时，你将让泰德去进行一些较小的冒险，以及你的远见卓识的想法。
I remember thinking for a while, and I think wrongly that we had to make episode three, dealing with like, how is Ted at integrating Robin into the group?
我记得想了一会儿，我认为我们必须制作第三集是错误的，比如，泰德如何将罗宾融入团队？
And I think in the end, it was a good decision not to do that.
我认为最终，不这样做是一个很好的决定。
It was like, Ted invited Robin in the group.
就像泰德邀请罗宾加入小组一样。
She's bonding with Lily, let Ted, don't make it about Ted and Robin.
她和莉莉关系很好，让泰德，别把事情闹腾到泰德和罗宾身上。
This one is something else.
这是另一回事。
And we knew we'd get to more of Ted and Robin later.
我们知道稍后我们会更多地了解泰德和罗宾。
I remember feeling like wanting to plant the seed of Lily's insecurity about getting engaged.
我记得当时我想种下莉莉对订婚缺乏安全感的种子。
Like, just have a little seed planted about, you know, this thing where she's like, I'm invisible now that I have this ring.
就像，只要种下一点种子，你知道，她就像，现在我有了这枚戒指，我就隐形了。
Now that she wants to go hook up with some other guy, Marshall, but it's usually what Josh said earlier.
现在她想和其他人勾搭，马歇尔，但这通常是乔希之前说的。
It's like my identity has shifted in some way.
就好像我的身份在某种程度上发生了变化。
A door has closed.
一扇门已经关闭。
I'm heading towards a kind of adulthood and the cement drying on my life a little bit.
我正走向成年，生活中的水泥正在一点点干燥。
We knew we wanted to plant seeds that Marshall and Lily as stable as they seem, they're still young, there still might be turbulence in their journey towards their wedding day.
我们知道我们想要播下种子，让马歇尔和莉莉像看起来一样稳定，他们还年轻，在他们的婚礼之路上仍然可能会遇到动荡。
We knew we wanted to plant that seed and we knew we wanted to show that Ted wasn't going to stop trying to go have crazy adventures just because he was like smitten with Robbins.
我们知道我们想播下这颗种子，我们知道我们想表明泰德不会仅仅因为迷上了罗宾斯就停止尝试疯狂的冒险。
We wanted to make those two sales, Barney and Ted going out on the town was going to be a speed of the show.
我们想要完成这两笔销售，巴尼和特德去镇上将成为展会的一个速度。
So I feel like we were doing long-term planning here.
所以我觉得我们正在这里做长期规划。
We were kind of planting a little something, a little bit of turbulence for Lily, even though it's light and silly in this episode.
我们有点为莉莉种下了一些东西，一点点动荡，尽管这一集里的事情既轻松又愚蠢。
It's there.
它就在那里。
And Ted's wrestling with whether Barney's going to help get him where he needs it to go.
泰德正在考虑巴尼是否会帮助他到达他需要的地方。
Do I really want to be dragged to Philadelphia for no reason, to hang out with two girls that have boyfriends.
我真的想无缘无故地被拖到费城，和两个有男朋友的女孩一起出去玩吗？
So I think like ending that episode, but Ted saying, future Ted saying, it was good than I hang out with Barney, I could get stuck in Russ and Barney could bust me out of them.
所以我想结束这一集，但泰德说，未来的泰德说，这比我和巴尼一起出去玩要好，我可能会陷入拉斯，巴尼可以把我从他们中救出来。
And acknowledging that is kind of saying the audience, like, you're going to see that story.
承认这一点就等于告诉观众，你会看到这个故事。
They're going to have fun adventures on this show.
他们将在这个节目中经历有趣的冒险。
And this old man, he must did me fell in love with you, new York City.
而这个老人，他一定让我爱上了你，纽约市。
And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
现在是广告，广告结束，回到演出。
I also thought, so this was something, Jordana and I were talking about.
我还想，这就是乔丹娜和我正在谈论的事情。
She didn't do a recording but she said, if you want to say that we talked about this thing, but something that jumped out to both of us was, there's a spiritual principle that we talk about all the time.
她没有录音，但她说，如果你想说我们谈论过这件事，但我们俩都突然想到，有一个精神原则我们一直在谈论。
three forces in the universe.
宇宙中的三种力量。
There's the creation, the force of creation, the force of maintenance and the force of destruction, right?
有创造、创造的力量、维持的力量和破坏的力量，对吗？
And there are these dynamic three forces, they're always going.
这三种动态力量始终存在。
And if you keep the creation force at the front of your life, that means risk taking chances, stepping into the unknown, trying new things, going new places, challenging yourself, then in the second place is maintenance where things that are working that are, that you wanna keep in your life, but that it has to be in the second position.
如果你把创造的力量放在你生活的前面，这意味着冒险，踏入未知，尝试新事物，去新地方，挑战自己，那么第二位就是维护那些正在发挥作用的东西，你想把它们保留在你的生活中，但它必须放在第二位。
And then naturally, the things that are irrelevant to your life go away.
然后自然地，与你的生活无关的事情就会消失。
The destruction operator takes care of all those.
销毁操作员负责处理所有这些事情。
However, if you elevate maintenance into the first position, okay, when you say, no, no, no, I just want things to stay the same.
然而，如果你把维护提升到第一位，好吧，当你说，不，不，不，我只是希望事情保持不变。
I don't wanna rock the boat.
我不想惹事生非。
I don't want anything new in treating our life.
我不想要任何新的东西来对待我们的生活。
It's all about familiarity and routine.
这一切都与熟悉和常规有关。
And you bump this creation operator down to number two, it provokes the destruction.
当你把这个创建操作符降到第二位时，它会引发破坏。
So it's like the universe wants you back in the unknown and the juicy good novel stuff, right?
所以这就好像宇宙希望你回到未知的、有趣的小说中，对吧？
That's a good theory.
这是一个很好的理论。
So if you look at your life and you see, oh my god, there's a destruction everywhere.
所以如果你审视自己的生活，你会发现，天啊，到处都是毁灭。
You should look and say, have I been living in too much in maintenance?
你应该看看并说，我是不是生活在维护中太多了？
Have I not been moving forward?
难道我就没有一直往前走吗？
Right?
正确的？
So we turn to each other and we're like, Barney is actually the force of creation in this.
所以我们转向彼此，我们想，巴尼实际上是这方面的创造力量。
And Ted keeps saying, especially at the beginning, I just want to be at my same bar with my same friends and my same drink like he's really arguing for a life of maintenance and familiarity and regularity.
特德一直说，尤其是在开始的时候，我只想和同样的朋友一起在同一个酒吧，喝同样的酒，就像他真正主张维持、熟悉和规律的生活一样。
And there's something about Barney.
还有一些关于巴尼的事情。
He's not quite the devil.
他并不完全是魔鬼。
He's actually like he's he's trying to shake Ted.
他实际上就像是在试图摆脱特德。
He's trying to shake the dust off of Ted and saying like your life will be better if you go on adventures with me.
他试图抖落特德身上的灰尘，并说如果你和我一起去冒险，你的生活会更好。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
That's a great way to look at this.
这是看待这个问题的好方法。
Like chaos as a creative force here.
就像这里的混乱一样是一种创造力。
Barney is chaos as a creative of force.
巴尼是混乱的创造力的力量。
And it is interesting because I and I think we could have written this better.
这很有趣，因为我和我认为我们可以写得更好。
I love that I'm listening regrets in this episode.
我喜欢在这一集里听到遗憾。
It's a really good episode.
这是一个非常好的剧集。
But I think we could have even made clearer because it's in there.
但我认为我们甚至可以说得更清楚，因为它就在那里。
I think Ted is saying I just want to be in my same bar because he just he didn't land the girl in episode two, right?
我想特德是在说我只想呆在同一个酒吧，因为他只是在第二集中没有找到那个女孩，对吗？
He didn't get Robin.
他没有得到罗宾。
He took a big risk.
他冒了很大的风险。
And it didn't pay off.
但它没有得到回报。
So he wants to retreat to that bar.
所以他想退到那个酒吧去。
And he goes, well, Robin walked into that bar.
他走了，好吧，罗宾走进了那个酒吧。
She was almost the one.
她几乎就是那个人了。
Maybe it'll happen again.
也许它会再次发生。
If I sit in this bar long enough, she'll walk in.
如果我在这家酒吧坐得够久，她就会走进来。
It's almost that same thing of the slutty pumpkin, right?
这和放荡的南瓜几乎是一样的，对吧？
Ted sitting up on top of the roof.
特德坐在屋顶上。
Like, I'm, she's going to come back.
就像，我，她会回来的。
And he wants, and it, it is like, I just want to, I want stasis.
他想要，就像，我只是想要，我想要停滞。
I want maintenance.
我要维护。
And that's not how things get created in the world.
世界上的事物并不是这样创造的。
And that's, yeah, Barney helps him break out of that.
是的，巴尼帮助他摆脱了困境。
But I wish we had said something like, spoken to the idea that because Ted was a little bruised by, you know, Robin Notting, let's be together, but that's part of his or treating to the bar like kind of a trident to the shell.
但我希望我们说过这样的话，谈到这样的想法，因为泰德被罗宾·诺丁弄伤了一点，让我们在一起吧，但这是他的一部分，或者对待酒吧就像对待贝壳的三叉戟一样。
I think we could have made that sell.
我认为我们本来可以卖出去的。
Well, I think that's what it was.
嗯，我想就是这样。
You made some Barney's subtext explicit, but you don't make Ted's explicit.
你明确了巴尼的一些潜台词，但没有明确特德的潜台词。
Yeah, can we get back into the episode?
是啊，我们能回到正剧吗？
We could add that.
我们可以补充一点。
So in some ways, maybe that would have helped me feel less like Ted was a wet blanket and more like, no, I'm licking my wounds, like my nerve endings got exposed and I got, I got cinched, you know?
所以在某些方面，也许这会让我感觉不像泰德是一条湿毯子，而更像是，不，我在舔我的伤口，就像我的神经末梢暴露了一样，我得到了，我被收紧了，你知道吗？
Yeah, I think that's what it was, but we didn't quite say it enough, honestly.
是的，我认为就是这样，但老实说，我们说得还不够。
So I'm going to be giving notes each week on what I'm trying to do.
因此，我每周都会记录我正在尝试做的事情。
I wish I would be thinking of that.
我希望我能想到这一点。
I don't think I was thinking of that.
我想我没有想到这一点。
I wish I had been thinking that.
我希望我一直这么想。
You know, I think that would have.
你知道，我想那会的。
You know what would have made you think that?
你知道什么会让你这么想吗？
If we fucking wrote it that way.
如果我们他妈的那样写的话。
I can only work with what I got.
我只能用我所拥有的来工作。
But that's that.
但就是这样。
I adore this episode and I think probably the reason we didn't make linger too much on that we might have gotten some notes of like it can't just be the Ted is hung up on Rob and show.
我喜欢这一集，我想这可能是我们没有过多停留的原因，我们可能会得到一些注释，比如这不仅仅是泰德对罗布和表演的关注。
It has to be fun, right?
它一定很有趣，对吧？
It has to be like a fun adventurous, get them out on the town and I think we were very like hung up on that.
这必须像一次有趣的冒险，让他们到城里去，我想我们对此非常着迷。
I do remember we were getting some notes from this studio network.
我记得我们从这个工作室网络得到了一些笔记。
Like, all right, show some fun speeds.
就像，好吧，展示一些有趣的速度。
Your sandwich between King of Queens and two and a half men, get some, get the boys out on the town trying to get laid.
你的三明治是皇后国王和两个半男人之间的，拿一些，让男孩们到城里去上床。
And also they were, I think they were thinking about if someone just tunes in and they haven't seen the first two episodes, is there, because I know there was a debate always about standalone versus thing kind of episodic sagas.
而且他们也，我认为他们正在考虑是否有人只是收听并且他们还没有看过前两集，因为我知道总是存在关于独立与情景传奇的争论。
So this is a pretty standalone episode.
所以这是一个非常独立的剧集。
Like you could just stumble look on this show in 2005 of October.
就像你可能在 2005 年 10 月偶然看到这个节目一样。
And you could watch it and be delighted because it presents its story and it wraps it up in 22 minutes, you know.
你可以观看它并感到高兴，因为它讲述了它的故事，并且在 22 分钟内结束了它，你知道。
Because that was the mission.
因为这就是使命。
That was the mission of this episode.
这就是本集的使命。
And it was sort of like almost involuntarily the mission because I think the suit in the network were like, great hour long, great two-parter.
这有点像几乎不由自主地执行任务，因为我认为网络中的套装就像是，很棒的一个小时，很棒的两方。
Now do you want that's like a little chocolate and a box of chocolates.
现在你想要一点巧克力和一盒巧克力吗？
And that's how all the CBS had come square at the time for better or second.
这就是当时所有哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）都在争先恐后地达成一致的原因。
I'm not even saying it's a bad thing.
我什至不是说这是一件坏事。
That's just what they did on CBS at that time.
这正是他们当时在哥伦比亚广播公司所做的。
And we needed to do some of that to fit in.
我们需要做一些事情来适应。
But what we love to do was to be more serialized.
但我们喜欢做的是更加系列化。
How do we have the courage to make this one a little more serialized at the beginning?
我们如何有勇气在一开始就把这个系列化一点呢？
I think we would have talked more about Ted bruised and licking his wounds, but we were just like we were given the notes like shoot these guys out of a cannon on a fun cartoon.
我想我们会更多地谈论泰德的瘀伤和舔他的伤口，但我们就像在一部有趣的卡通片中得到的注释一样，比如用大炮射击这些家伙。
And in a way that is what's great about the episode.
从某种程度上来说，这就是这一集的精彩之处。
So I don't really regret it.
所以我真的不后悔。
Can I ask real quick where did you get the where did the untucked shirt bit come from?
我能快速问一下你从哪里得到那件没塞进裤子里的衬衫是从哪里来的吗？
I don't know where that came from.
我不知道那是从哪里来的。
Well you know what I think it was.
好吧，你知道我的想法是什么。
I think for the first two two episodes I had some untucked shirts going.
我想在前两集里，我有一些衬衫没塞进去。
You went untucked shirts.
你把衬衫解开。
So it was already established as a look, right?
所以它的外观已经确定了，对吧？
It was a look.
这是一个眼神。
Yeah, and it's, and Barney hates, it's like tucked the shirt.
是的，巴尼讨厌这样，就像把衬衫塞进裤子里一样。
Like I think it was just Barney, like you're un-sued.
就像我认为这只是巴尼干的，就像你没有被起诉一样。
You're not in his suit, that's bad enough.
你没穿他的西装，这已经够糟糕的了。
But if you're gonna have a blazer on a shirt, tuck in the goddamn shirt.
但如果你想在衬衫上穿一件西装外套，就把那该死的衬衫塞进去。
I think it was just, Barney just wants Ted to do what he says.
我认为巴尼只是希望泰德按他说的去做。
That's his main drive.
这是他的主要动力。
In some ways, in all of the first three episodes that's his main drive, maybe more than getting laid.
从某些方面来说，在前三集中，这是他的主要动力，也许不仅仅是上床。
I mean, again, they do not hook up in this episode.
我的意思是，他们在这一集里并没有勾搭。
It's sort of delightful, because I think it really proves that thing of like Barney and Ted, Barney and Ted, Barney and Ted do not get with ladies.
这有点令人愉快，因为我认为这确实证明了像巴尼和泰德、巴尼和泰德、巴尼和泰德这样的人不适合女士。
So they don't look up together.
所以他们不会一起抬头。
Wait a minute.
等一下。
I realize how I consider him as a spoiler.
我意识到我是如何把他视为剧透的。
Is Barney and Ted get together at the end of season one?
巴尼和泰德会在第一季结束时聚在一起吗？
No, but Barney and Ted do not succeed either of them in getting the girl in this episode.
不，但是巴尼和泰德在这一集中都没有成功地得到那个女孩。
And I kind of love the seeds that plants have just held like, Barney really doesn't, he does not have nearly the success rate.
我有点喜欢植物刚刚持有的种子，巴尼真的不喜欢，他几乎没有成功率。
But if you really look at a lot of these episodes, like he's really just, he's, he's, there's a lot of 83% lying happening here to come.
但如果你真的看很多这样的情节，就像他真的只是，他是，他是，有很多83％的谎言正在发生。
And I think also part of Barney's eternal fascination with Ted is he won't obey him.
我认为巴尼对泰德永远着迷的部分原因是他不会服从他。
Like he won't give him what he wants.
就像他不会给他他想要的一样。
He doesn't let him change his life.
他不允许他改变自己的生活。
I mean, he doesn't incrementally.
我的意思是，他不会逐渐增加。
But he, there's something, you know, it's kind of like, Barney's like a lot of seducers, like love the chase, But they don't like it when someone turns around and says, okay, you know, it's really true.
但他，有一些东西，你知道，有点像，巴尼就像很多诱惑者一样，喜欢追逐，但他们不喜欢有人转身说，好吧，你知道，这真的是真的。
He is trying to cast a sort of a thrall over Ted in these episodes much more than overwhelming.
在这些剧集中，他试图对泰德施以一种奴役，而不仅仅是压倒性的。
And in the end, he doesn't care.
最后，他不在乎。
He's like, all right, we're not getting laid tonight, but we're gonna do something legendary.
他说，好吧，我们今晚不会上床，但我们会做一些传奇的事情。
We're gonna give it and make it a story we'll always tell.
我们将把它变成一个我们永远讲述的故事。
And he does, he does it.
他做到了，他做到了。
He does that magic trick, he's that friend.
他会表演那个魔术，他就是那个朋友。
And I think we all have friends like this where we like, we never would have had that story without that friend.
我想我们都有这样的朋友，如果没有那个朋友，我们永远不会有这样的故事。
And that is a gift and life is short.
这是一份礼物，而生命是短暂的。
And you end up years and years later, what are the stories you remember, what are the stories you're gonna tell?
年复一年之后，你还记得哪些故事，你要讲述哪些故事？
And Barney gives you that.
巴尼给了你这个。
Barney gives you that.
I would like to say to any of our listeners, if you have licked the Liberty Bell, or if you're a security guard at the Liberty Bell, and you've had to stop people or knowing what they're doing, you'll let them get away with it from licking the Liberty Bell, we'd like to hear from you.
我想对我们的任何一位听众说，如果你舔过自由钟，或者如果你是自由钟的保安，你必须阻止人们或知道他们在做什么，你会让他们逃脱舔自由钟的惩罚，我们希望听到你的声音。
We'd like to hear what your experience was with that.
我们想听听您对此的体验。
We're not endorsing or encouraging.
我们并不赞同或鼓励。
Not endorsing it.
不赞同。
But if you've already done it and you took a picture of it, we would like to see it.
但如果您已经完成并拍了照片，我们很想看看。
We would like to see it.
我们希望看到它。
Don't go to waste.
不要浪费。
It's if you did it.
就是如果你做到了。
Yeah.
是的。
At how we made your, what's the thing?
我们是如何制作你的，是怎么回事？
How we made your mother?
我们是如何造就你母亲的？
How we made your mother.
我们如何造就了你的母亲。
At how we made your mother on Instagram.
了解我们如何在 Instagram 上塑造你的母亲。
How many did I count?
我数了一下有多少个？
And go to contact.
并去联系。
Yeah.
是的。
Right.
正确的。
Let us.
让我们。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
Yeah.
是的。
I have a question.
我有一个问题。
I've already been, my mind's already been blown in these first two episodes about Barney in particular, I have the good fortune of a terrible memory.
我已经，特别是在关于巴尼的前两集里，我的思想已经被震撼了，我很幸运有一个可怕的记忆。
So I am watching this show almost new.
所以我几乎是全新观看这个节目。
I have forgotten quite a bit along the way.
一路上我已经忘记了很多。
And the idea of Barney being, I'm going to compare it as I will do several times to Eyes Wide Shut to Stanley Goodberg.
我将把巴尼的想法与斯坦利·古德伯格的《大开眼戒》进行多次比较。
So there's a scene at the end of Eyes Wide Shut where Sydney Pollock explains everything to Tom Cruise that just happened in this movie.
所以在《大开眼戒》的结尾有一个场景，西德尼·波洛克向汤姆·克鲁斯解释了电影中刚刚发生的一切。
People complained about this as you're just telling him, or at least the end.
人们抱怨这件事，因为你只是告诉他，或者至少是结局。
And it was years later that's a writer pointed out, you don't have to believe what he's saying.
多年后，一位作家指出，你不必相信他说的话。
Maybe he's lying the whole time, right, and that gives you a whole new, oh, right.
也许他一直在撒谎，对吧，这给了你一个全新的，哦，对的。
You've made a big assumption, but hold on, same thing with Barney.
你做了一个很大的假设，但是等一下，巴尼也是如此。
I think that, and maybe it's my bad memory.
我是这么想的，也许是我记性不好。
The idea that he's making a lot of his stories up, or that he's not the Lothario and he hasn't been with that many women, is kind of new in my head right now and maybe I'm just forgetting things that I should have known.
他编造了很多故事，或者他不是色狼，也没有和那么多女人交往过，这种想法现在在我的脑海里有点新鲜，也许我只是忘记了我应该知道的事情。
When you were writing him, when you were first creating him, I know he's based on some some people that you knew.
当你写他的时候，当你第一次创造他的时候，我知道他是基于你认识的一些人的。
What was the essence of it?
它的本质是什么？
Was it, we need this kind of wild guy character who's going to all be about the hunt?
是不是，我们需要这种狂野的、专注于狩猎的家伙角色？
Was it, we need a kind of broken soul who's covering it with with this adventure?
是不是，我们需要一种破碎的灵魂来用这次冒险来掩盖它？
It was wanting to see the broken soul beneath toxic masculinity.
它想看到有毒的男子气概下破碎的灵魂。
It was wanting to parody toxic masculinity and then humanize it by showing all over the broken parts underneath.
它想要模仿有毒的男子气概，然后通过展示下面所有破碎的部分来将其人性化。
And then you do nine seasons of it.
然后你就拍了九季。
And along the way, sometimes it just becomes like, let's do a funny joke about Bernie trying to get laid and you kind of lose some of that at moments.
一路上，有时它会变得像，让我们讲一个关于伯尼试图上床的有趣笑话，而你有时会失去一些。
But I think the through line for me and why why I don't look at it like, oh, we couldn't get away with that today.
但我认为这对我来说是一条贯穿始终的路线，为什么我不这么看，哦，我们今天无法摆脱这一点。
I it always at the intention was always let's show how broken this guy is underneath the suit and then show hints of him trying to grow and heal throughout the series and end him up somewhere different than he then he started.
我的目的始终是让我们展示这个家伙在套装下有多么破碎，然后展示他在整个系列中试图成长和治愈的暗示，并最终让他到达与他开始时不同的地方。
And I also think whatever whether you're a guy who's obsessed with getting laid and meeting women and not that successful at it or you're part of like pick up culture and you actually are successful with it.
我还认为，无论你是一个痴迷于上床和结识女性但在这方面不太成功的人，还是你属于“搭讪文化”的一部分，而且你实际上在这方面很成功。
Both of them carry a lot of pain underneath them.
两人的内心都承受着巨大的痛苦。
They do.
他们确实这么做了。
You don't behave that way single-mindedly and almost psychotically if you're not feeling some sort of great absence at the center of your heart.
如果你的内心没有感受到某种巨大的缺席，你就不会一心一意地、近乎精神病地做出这样的行为。
I know.
我知道。
For 100%.
为 100%。
addiction.
瘾。
It's like filling a hole.
这就像填一个洞。
It really is like a missing piece in somebody.
这真的就像某人身上缺失的一块。
Yeah.
是的。
That's how I look at Barney.
我就是这么看巴尼的。
And that's why I have such, I've on him so endearing in these early episodes because I see that spark, I see that initial idea in him in these episodes.
这就是为什么我在这些早期剧集中对他如此喜爱，因为我在这些剧集中看到了他的火花，我看到了他最初的想法。
Well, one of the fascinating, I think kind of tensions in the show is I think you and Carter would say, no, we always saw him as kind of sad and broken but trying.
好吧，我认为节目中令人着迷的紧张局势之一是我认为你和卡特会说，不，我们总是认为他有点悲伤和破碎，但在努力。
And he doesn't get laid nearly as much as he claims to.
而且他并没有像他声称的那样经常上床。
Whereas I think Neil would disagree with you.
但我认为尼尔会不同意你的观点。
I think Neil thought, Neil played him as if he was getting late every night.
我想尼尔想，尼尔把他打得好像他每天晚上都迟到一样。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, I think that's some of the interesting tension of the character.
我的意思是，我认为这就是这个角色的一些有趣的张力。
Well, it's funny because Neil, I mean, it was like a superhero outfit.
嗯，这很有趣，因为尼尔，我的意思是，它就像超级英雄的服装。
Neil had to put on every week, right?
尼尔每周都必须穿上，对吗？
It was Batman.
是蝙蝠侠。
It was Iron Man.
那是钢铁侠。
He had to put this on and be that superhero and perform that and believe his own stories.
他必须穿上它，成为那个超级英雄，表演它，并相信自己的故事。
And then those moments where we did have him step out of that and show some other side, they were very effective because of how much he had committed to the first thing.
然后，我们确实让他走出困境并展现出另一面的那些时刻，它们非常有效，因为他对第一件事做出了巨大的承诺。
And I always found myself more jealous of the other characters, because I thought they all had costumes that I wasn't allowed to wear.
我总是发现自己更嫉妒其他角色，因为我认为他们都穿着我不被允许穿的服装。
Yeah, like I thought they all had some armor up around them that allowed them to, I don't know, float through the world of how I met your mother in a less just vulnerable way.
是的，就像我以为他们周围都有一些盔甲，让他们能够，我不知道，以一种不那么脆弱的方式漂浮在我遇见你母亲的世界中。
I mean, everyone had their vulnerable moments to be sure I'm not taking that away from anyone, but Ted just, he didn't have that armor.
我的意思是，每个人都有脆弱的时刻，以确保我不会从任何人那里夺走这一点，但特德只是，他没有那副盔甲。
I had to kind of have my nerve endings exposed for nine years.
我的神经末梢必须暴露九年。
Yeah, you were on your own a lot of the time because Marshall had Lily and that meant sort of Siegel had handing into bond with.
是的，很多时候你都是独自一人，因为马​​歇尔有莉莉，这意味着西格尔已经与他建立了联系。
Robin was supposed to be this thing.
罗宾本来就是这样的。
Ted couldn't have, right?
特德不可能有，对吧？
You couldn't fully connect with that character.
你无法完全与那个角色建立联系。
Those two characters weren't gonna get together right away.
这两个角色不会立即聚在一起。
And Barney's inside this Darth Vader outfit.
巴尼穿着这身达斯·维德服装。
And Ted is a little bit like, on his own little island.
泰德有点像，在他自己的小岛上。
Well, it's almost like everybody but like no one likes first dates.
嗯，几乎每个人都一样，但没有人喜欢第一次约会。
I mean most of them are bad.
我的意思是他们中的大多数都很糟糕。
And Ted had hundreds, you know, like, like there is a feeling that he he couldn't settle.
特德有数百个，你知道，就像有一种他无法安定下来的感觉。
He couldn't land the plane of what he most wanted.
他无法让他最想要的飞机降落。
But I think also, you know, much like Barney, like everyone, you know, when I was editing my first movie, I worked with his great editor Michael Miller for both my movies.
但我也认为，你知道，就像巴尼一样，就像每个人一样，你知道，当我剪辑我的第一部电影时，我与他伟大的剪辑师迈克尔·米勒一起工作了我的两部电影。
and he used to say movies and television are very different for this one reason.
他曾经说过，出于这个原因，电影和电视是非常不同的。
In movies, you have to show transformation in 90 minutes or two hours because that's the whole time you have allotted.
在电影中，你必须在 90 分钟或两个小时内展现转变，因为那是你分配的全部时间。
In TV, if you're going to change them at all, it's so incremental because you're trying to keep people watching and you're kind of hitting these things.
在电视领域，如果你要改变它们，那是渐进式的，因为你试图让人们继续观看，并且你会触及这些东西。
Now, I think you guys split the difference on this really well in terms of letting characters evolve over nine years.
现在，我认为你们在让角色在九年的时间里进化方面很好地区分了这一点。
But still, they would come back to what was in their DNA pretty regularly.
但尽管如此，他们还是会经常回到自己 DNA 中的东西。
Yeah.
是的。
That's right.
这是正确的。
That was always the balancing act.
这始终是一种平衡行为。
That was always, we don't want to be stuck in the same route.
一直如此，我们不想陷入同一条道路。
We want to change them up, but they have to have a through line and Ted changed season to season, but there were moments where, yeah, there were so many moments where Ted had to be the vulnerable one, where you had to put your heart out there to get sort of stomped on.
我们想要改变他们，但他们必须有一条贯穿的路线，特德在一个又一个赛季都在改变，但有些时候，是的，有很多时候，特德必须是脆弱的，你必须全心全意地被踩在脚下。
We've talked about this and we will talk about this more.
我们已经讨论过这个问题，我们还将进一步讨论这个问题。
But the first two seasons, I think I really was looking for how am I similar to this guy.
但前两个赛季，我想我真的在寻找我和这个人有什么相似之处。
And then at some point, I just I just went off in different directions.
然后在某个时刻，我只是朝着不同的方向前进。
And I thought, no, that's not even psychologically helpful anymore.
我想，不，这在心理上已经没有帮助了。
I'm just going to play him as a character.
我只是把他当作一个角色来扮演。
And I didn't take it as personally.
我并不认为这是针对我个人的。
I didn't, you know, and so in some ways I think I played it better that way by by recognizing like, this is a job.
你知道，我没有，所以在某些方面，我认为我通过认识到这是一份工作，从而更好地发挥了作用。
This is a guy is not me.
这是一个人，不是我。
But you have You've only got yourself to use, you know, for it.
但你只有你自己可以利用，你知道，为此。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you think even unconsciously playing Ted for that long made you want to be less like Ted in your personal life in some way to send you?
你是否认为，即使无意识地扮演 Ted 这么久，你是否也想在个人生活中以某种方式变得不像 Ted？
Did it make you not want to like settle down and find the girl and have that in your main drive?
这是否让你不想安定下来找到那个女孩并将其放在你的主要驱动器中？
Did it make you want to go have more adventures?
这是否让你想要去经历更多的冒险？
Well, I didn't get married until pretty late.
嗯，我很晚才结婚。
So maybe.
所以也许吧。
No, no, no, no.
不，不，不，不。
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, unconscious level where you're like, I'm, I did this thing for a decade, I'm not going to try to, I'm going to try to be something else in my life.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, unconscious level where you're like, I'm, I did this thing for a decade, I'm not going to try to,我将尝试成为我生活中的其他人。
I just wonder if one informed the other.
我只是想知道一个人是否通知了另一个人。
I have to pay you a couple hundred dollars and have you be accredited in a different way for me to, to start answering that.
我必须付给你几百美元，并让你以不同的方式获得认可，才能开始回答这个问题。
All right, Craig, well, this is the part of the episode where we turn to our listener viewer mail.
好吧，克雷格，好，这是本集的一部分，我们将转向听众观众的邮件。
We have a title for this segment yet.
我们还没有为这个片段定一个标题。
I was pitching how we read your letter, But how we read your letters I think pretty good.
我正在推销我们如何阅读你的信，但我认为我们如何阅读你的信相当不错。
All right, let's go with it.
好吧，我们就这样吧。
It's thematically consistent.
它在主题上是一致的。
Let's do it branded hashtag branded.
让我们做品牌主题标签品牌。
Well, can play how we how we read your letter.
好吧，可以玩我们如何读你的信。
If you want to write into us and tell us what how I met your mother means to you or any other beautiful beloved hilarious how I met your mother related story Go to how we made your mother calm go to contact and it should be pretty clear from there right Alec We love hearing from you guys.
如果你想写信给我们，告诉我们我如何遇见你母亲对你意味着什么，或者任何其他美丽可爱的搞笑我如何遇见你母亲相关的故事去我们如何让你母亲平静去联系，从那里应该很清楚亚历克我们很高兴收到你们的来信。
Yeah, we do.
是的，我们愿意。
We really do.
我们确实如此。
This is the best.
这是最好的。
It's the most meaningful to hear these letters.
听到这些信是最有意义的。
I'm going to read one This is from Serenity.
我要读一本《这是来自宁静》。
Hi Josh.
嗨乔什。
Hi Serenity.
嗨，宁静。
How I met your mother has been my favorite show and has deeply impacted my life I've watched it literally countless times now growing up.
《我如何认识你母亲》是我最喜欢的节目，对我的生活产生了深远的影响，在我的成长过程中，我已经看过无数次了。
I have the complete series in DVD form The show deeply resonates with me.
我有完整系列的 DVD 版本。这个节目深深地引起了我的共鸣。
It taught me the importance of patience, vulnerability, and staying true to what I want in life It may be believed that true love is worth waiting for and that every moment good or bad shapes who we become I often find myself thinking about lessons from the show when navigating my own life It is influenced the way I approach love friendship and how I view the world in general It's a reminder to keep believing in love to cherish the people around me and to never give up on my dreams no matter how far away They might seem Thank you for bringing Ted to life in such an authentic way your performance and the lessons the show expressed will always hold a special place in my heart and continue to shape who I am as a person wishing you the best serenity.
它教会了我耐心、脆弱和忠于我在生活中想要的东西的重要性人们相信真爱是值得等待的，每一刻的好或坏都会塑造我们成为什么样的人我经常发现自己在导航自己的生活时思考节目中的教训它影响了我处理爱情友谊的方式以及我如何看待整个世界它提醒我要继续相信爱情，珍惜我周围的人，永远不要放弃我的梦想，无论它们看起来有多遥远谢谢你把特德带到了生活中以真实的方式，你的表演和节目所表达的教训将永远在我心中占有特殊的位置，并继续塑造我作为一个人，祝你拥有最好的平静。
How nice is that?
那有多好？
Thank you, serenity.
谢谢你，平静。
So beautiful.
如此美丽。
You know what occurred to me, Craig, when we're talking about part of this show is the mystery of what it is about this show, why it's so beloved, why people keep watching it and watching it and showing it to their kids and quoting it.
你知道我想到了什么，克雷格，当我们谈论这个节目的一部分时，我想到的是这个节目的神秘之处，为什么它如此受人喜爱，为什么人们不断地观看它并向他们的孩子展示它并引用它。
As I was reading that, I thought there's something about movies and TV, a lot of it presents an incredibly idealized version of life and a sanitized version of life.
当我读到这篇文章时，我认为电影和电视有一些东西，其中很多都呈现了令人难以置信的理想化版本的生活和净化后的生活版本。
And I think something people find relieving about this show is it's actually, it's about, it's much about good time, as bad times as good times, it's about people getting knocked down holding those they love close and moving forward, you know, wound it, but moving forward.
我认为这部剧让人们感到宽慰的是，它实际上是关于美好时光的，无论是坏时光还是美好时光，它是关于人们被击倒时紧紧抓住他们所爱的人并继续前进，你知道，伤害它，但继续前进。
It's a really a show, I think a big word is resilience.
这真的是一场表演，我认为一个重要的词就是韧性。
Certainly for Ted when people say, why do you love Ted?
当人们说“你为什么爱泰德？”时，当然是针对泰德的。
I said, he's the most resilient character.
我说，他是最有韧性的人物。
You know, he's like a bobble head or like, you know, those things get knocked down.
你知道，他就像一个摇头娃娃，或者像那些东西会被撞倒。
They just pop back up.
他们只是突然回来。
And I think that there's something people need to be reminded.
我认为有一些事情需要提醒人们。
Life is not a series.
生活不是一个系列。
You don't go from triumph to triumph, to triumph.
你不会从胜利走向胜利，再走向胜利。
That's not a life you would want to live in.
那不是你想要的生活。
It's not a life where you're going to learn all that much.
这不是你能学到那么多东西的生活。
And when people talk about the most meaningful moments of their life, it's generally related to some heartbreak or setback or failure where they were able to reassess, reprioritize.
当人们谈论生命中最有意义的时刻时，通常与一些心碎、挫折或失败有关，在这些时刻他们能够重新评估、重新确定优先顺序。
Um, and how many are mothers just laced through with all of that?
嗯，有多少母亲刚刚经历过这一切？
As I was listening to that letter, I was thinking, even with the shows I absolutely love, are there any other shows that someone would say this about?
当我听那封信时，我在想，即使有我绝对喜欢的节目，还有其他节目有人会这么说吗？
They've influenced the way I approached love, friendship, and how I view the world in general.
他们影响了我对待爱情、友谊的方式，以及我看待世界的方式。
Like, that's not sign fell.
就像，这不是摔倒的迹象。
That was our, that was our move.
那是我们的，那是我们的举动。
We committed to our move very hard.
我们非常努力地致力于我们的行动。
We were not the funniest show.
我们不是最有趣的节目。
We were not the most joke dance show.
我们不是最搞笑的舞蹈表演。
I remember watching other shows, like 30 rock and being like, God damn they've got more jokes than we do and feeling insecure about it.
我记得看过其他节目，比如《30 rock》，我就想，该死的，他们的笑话比我们多，而且对此感到不安全。
But we said no it's okay we're in our land it's we're funny too but we're gonna do this other thing we're gonna throw a bunch of the bandwidth at this other thing and in the end it seems to be what has resonated with people for the most but it's interesting because I think part of the long tail of it because you encoded that into the DNA yeah it made it into a classic and it made it into a show that people still are watching and talk about because if you're doing, if you're going to do, this is not a slam against any show, but if you're going to do purely a joke show, you actually are in danger of it aging pretty quickly because it tastes in comedy change.
但我们说不，没关系，我们在我们的土地上，我们也很有趣，但我们要做另一件事，我们要在另一件事上投入大量带宽，最终这似乎是最能引起人们共鸣的事情，但很有趣，因为我认为它的长尾的一部分，因为你将它编码到 DNA 中，是的，它使它成为一个经典，它使它成为一个人们仍在观看和谈论的节目，因为如果你在做，如果你要做的，这并不是对任何节目的猛烈抨击，但如果你打算纯粹做一个笑话节目，你实际上面临着它很快老化的危险，因为它尝起来有喜剧变化的味道。
Yes, and references change.
是的，参考文献发生了变化。
And references change.
并且参考文献发生了变化。
But if you do a show that's really about these perennial ideas about love, friendship, family, resilience, good times, bad times, weathering, good times, bad times, like You have a better shot at creating something a little more timeless.
但如果你制作的节目确实是关于爱情、友谊、家庭、韧性、好时光、坏时光、风化、好时光、坏时光等永恒观念的节目，那么你就有更好的机会创造一些更永恒的东西。
Yeah.
是的。
It's kind of are you a cartoon or are you a movie, even if you're sitcom, you can steer it either way, and we're definitely more a movie.
这就像你是一部卡通片还是一部电影，即使你是情景喜剧，你也可以以任何一种方式引导它，而我们绝对更像是一部电影。
And occasionally we are cartooned by a Barney.
有时我们会被巴尼卡通化。
Okay.
好的。
Speaking of amazing letters from our fans, this letter comes from Vic.
说到我们粉丝的精彩来信，这封信来自维克。
I really appreciate it if you share this.
如果您分享这个，我真的很感激。
I'm going to try to not get emotional while I read this one.
当我读这篇文章时，我会尽量不情绪化。
Okay, here we go.
好的，我们开始吧。
Hymium has a special place in my heart that is hard to put into words.
Hymium 在我心中有着难以言喻的特殊地位。
It was the one thing that brought me comfort in the most difficult time of my life.
这是在我一生中最困难的时刻给我带来安慰的一件事。
My son was born needing an organ transplant, 2011, which meant we lived in the hospital for months at a time.
2011 年，我的儿子出生，需要进行器官移植，这意味着我们一次在医院住了几个月。
I was already a fan, watched on television, but it was the seasons on DVD that ultimately allowed me to, if only even for an episode, unload all of the worry and stress and just laugh and get lost in all the amazingly written, directed, acted adventures with the gang.
我已经是一名粉丝，在电视上观看过，但最终让我（即使只是一集）摆脱了所有的担忧和压力，只是笑，迷失在与这帮人一起编写、导演和表演的所有令人惊叹的冒险中。
Season one is classic, starting to set up the gags and groundwork for our group.
第一季很经典，开始为我们的团队设置笑点和基础。
I apologize for the length of this.
对于本文的长度，我深表歉意。
I appreciate whoever reads this.
我很感激读到这篇文章的人。
Thank you, Craig Thomas and Carter Bayes and thank you, Josh Radner, for bringing had the life for so many years.
谢谢克雷格·托马斯和卡特·贝叶斯，谢谢乔什·拉德纳，感谢你们给我们带来了这么多年的生活。
Thank you all for creating and producing this podcast.
感谢大家创建和制作这个播客。
I want to talk about why that means so much to me, and I'll definitely talk about this more later in the podcast when we get up to the part in the series where I went through something very similar to this.
我想谈谈为什么这对我来说意义重大，当我们进入系列中我经历过与此非常相似的事情的部分时，我肯定会在播客中更多地谈论这一点。
Between year two and three of how I met your mother, my son was born and we had no idea until he was born, that he had something called Jacob's syndrome, which meant it's a genetic deletion where he's missing a part of one of his 11th chromosomes, it meant that he needed open heart surgery a two week sold weighing about three and a half pounds.
在我遇见你母亲的第二年和第三年之间，我的儿子出生了，直到他出生我们才知道他患有一种叫做雅各氏综合症的疾病，这意味着这是一种基因缺失，他失去了第11条染色体的一部分，这意味着他需要两周的心脏直视手术，出售的体重约为三磅半。
It meant that he would have lifelong health problems and developmental challenges.
这意味着他将面临终生的健康问题和发育挑战。
It meant that he would be, you know, he would be on a different journey.
这意味着他将踏上不同的旅程。
He would be, we would be now special needs parents.
他将是，我们现在将成为有特殊需要的父母。
And we would be, we would be living sort of a different life than we thought we would be.
我们将会过着与我们想象的不同的生活。
And then it was, you know, it was year three being ended.
然后，你知道，第三年就结束了。
It was like, let's get back into the writers and we always I always used to joke to Carter and now go be funny.
就像，让我们回到编剧们身上，我总是对卡特开玩笑，现在变得有趣了。
We spent six weeks in the NICU, the neonatal intensive care unit at Children's Hospital of LA, which saved my son's life.
我们在洛杉矶儿童医院的新生儿重症监护室 NICU 度过了六个星期，这挽救了我儿子的生命。
Thank you, CHLA.
谢谢你，CHLA。
My son is 17 now and doing great.
我儿子现在17岁了，表现很好。
The making of the show, when we went back and started doing season three, getting the escape of making this show with these wonderful people who I loved and all the writers and Pam Freiman and Susie and Josh Radner and the whole cast, getting to escape into this other universe that was a universe full of love, a show about love, and a show about the hard times that making those episodes got me through the darkest time in my life.
当我们回去开始制作第三季时，我们逃离了与我所爱的这些出色的人以及所有编剧、帕姆·弗雷曼、苏西和乔什·拉德纳以及整个演员一起制作这部剧的过程，逃离到了另一个宇宙，这是一个充满爱的宇宙，一部关于爱的剧，一部关于制作这些剧集的艰难时期的剧，帮助我度过了人生中最黑暗的时期。
So then when I hear from fans, as we just see with that letter, that the show helped them get through their hard time.
因此，当我从粉丝那里听到时，正如我们刚刚从那封信中看到的那样，这部剧帮助他们度过了困难时期。
Well, it did that for me, and I think some of that energy made it into the show as everybody on the show rallied around me.
嗯，它为我做到了这一点，我认为当节目中的每个人都聚集在我周围时，其中一些能量就融入到了节目中。
Josh, you rallied around me, you would always, we would sit there and have long talks after the bath or rap at the bar and we would sit there and we would talk about what I was going through in Pam Fryman would be there in Susie and Carter and all the writers.
乔什，你聚集在我身边，你总是会，我们会坐在那里，在洗完澡或在酒吧说唱后进行长时间的交谈，我们会坐在那里，我们会谈论我在帕姆·弗莱曼、苏西和卡特以及所有作家中所经历的事情。
And it just meant the world to me.
它对我来说意味着整个世界。
And I think the show sort of took on some of that energy for me and with me.
我认为这部剧为我和我带来了一些能量。
And when I hear that it connects to people to this day who've gone through things like that, like I know what it's like to be in that NICU in that hospital for weeks and weeks on and not knowing if your kid's gonna live or die.
当我听到它时，它与那些经历过类似事情的人们联系在一起，就像我知道在这家医院的新生儿重症监护室呆上几周又几周而不知道你的孩子是生还是死是什么感觉。
And my son could have not made it.
我儿子不可能成功。
But he made it, and he's 17 now.
但他做到了，现在他17岁了。
And yeah, that was my journey throughout the middle part of how much your mother and now I just have this wonderful human being who's 17, who I play music with, he plays the drums, I play the guitar, he's got all these amazing strengths and things I never could have imagined when he was first born and so many gifts.
是的，这就是我整个旅程的中间部分，你的母亲和现在我有一个很棒的人，他17岁，我和他一起演奏音乐，他打鼓，我弹吉他，他拥有所有这些惊人的优势和我在他刚出生时从未想象过的东西，还有这么多的天赋。
And I will just say now, thank you, for sharing that story.
我现在只想说，谢谢你分享这个故事。
It means the world to me.
这对我来说意味着整个世界。
It's what I went through, the fact that it helped the show helped you get through what you were going through.
这就是我所经历的，事实上它帮助了节目帮助你度过了你正在经历的事情。
And even in some small way means the world.
甚至在某种程度上也意味着世界。
That's why that's why that's why we made the show.
这就是我们制作这个节目的原因。
That's what the show was to me and making the show.
这就是这部剧对我和制作这部剧的意义。
So thank you so much.
非常感谢。
And I would just say that we will talk more about this.
我只想说我们会更多地讨论这个问题。
We will talk about more about how sort of this big life chapter change for me and what I went through sort of informed how much your mother and in those seasons and stuff we're not there yet we just finished talking about episode three so I won't believe it for too long but I will say Josh and Alec and my wonderful friends making this podcast with me have all embraced sort of the fundraising and the cause that helps kids like my son it is part of the podcast thanks to them and if you go to our website howemadeyourmother.com and you go to the section called how you make a difference you can read all about the work being done by this amazing doctor named Dr. Paul Grossfeld out of UCSD radius children's hospital in San Diego.
我们将更多地谈论这个人生大篇章对我来说是如何改变的，以及我经历过的事情，告诉你母亲在那些季节和我们还没到的地方有多少，我们刚刚谈论完第三集，所以我不会相信它太久，但我会说乔什和亚历克以及我和我一起制作这个播客的好朋友都接受了筹款和帮助像我儿子这样的孩子的事业，感谢他们，这是播客的一部分，如果你访问我们的网站访问 howemadeyourmother.com，然后转到名为“如何做出改变”的部分，您可以阅读有关圣地亚哥 UCSD Radius 儿童医院这位名叫 Paul Grossfeld 博士的出色医生所做工作的所有信息。
And he is the worldwide expert in Jacobson syndrome.
他是雅各布森综合症的全球专家。
He is working to do research to help kids form with contendable heart defects of all different kinds, including the kind my son had, including Jacobson syndrome and the specifics about that and the developmental stuff.
他正在努力进行研究，以帮助患有各种不同类型的可对抗心脏缺陷的孩子，包括我儿子患有的那种，包括雅各布森综合症以及有关该疾病和发育问题的具体情况。
He is like the ex the worldwide expert in my son's condition among many other And he's like the best student in the world at Josh and I and we've all become dear friends with him now He the impact he's made on my life and the community of parents like me is it can't it can't be overstated He's like a guiding light as this candle in the darkness And so we raised money for him via this podcast So please go to how we made your mother calm Click on make a difference and you can read about that work if you feel like supporting this amazing work This is like ground-breaking, life-saving work that Paul Grossfeld does in San Diego.
他就像是我儿子病情方面的前世界专家，他就像是我和乔什世界上最好的学生，我们现在都成为了他的好朋友，他对我的生活和像我这样的父母社区产生的影响是不可言喻的，他就像黑暗中的蜡烛一样的指路明灯所以我们通过这个播客为他筹集了资金所以请转到我们如何让你的母亲平静点击做出改变，你可以如果您想支持这项令人惊叹的工作，请阅读该工作。这就像保罗·格罗斯菲尔德在圣地亚哥所做的开创性的、拯救生命的工作。
Please, if you can contribute in support or get the word out about it, we'd be honored.
如果您能提供支持或宣传此事，我们将不胜荣幸。
And thank you so much to everybody out there and the Hemium fandom that for sharing your vulnerability and sharing your life stories with me to this effect, it means the world to me to hear it.
非常感谢大家和 Hemium 粉丝们，感谢你们与我分享你们的脆弱，并与我分享你们的生活故事，这对我来说意义重大。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被宽恕了。
New York City.
纽约市。
What city?
哪个城市？
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lem, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lem 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point de Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point de Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Ragnar, special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connards.
我们的主题曲是 Josh Ragnar 的《NYC》，特别感谢 Lola Kennedy 和 Elliot Connards。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Ragnar's newsletters on substack.
在 substack 上订阅 Josh Ragnar 的时事通讯。
read Kreg Thomas' published prose at KregThomasWriter.com and you can subscribe to my dead father's society also on Substack.
阅读 Kreg Thomas 在 KregThomasWriter.com 上发表的散文，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
people will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
The real question, it just hit me, am I in love with you or just knew your city?
真正的问题，它让我震惊，我是爱你还是只是了解你的城市？